So Leute da bin ich, ich bin gerade eben erst ein Rechner wieder und gleich Stream angemacht.
Das heißt ich habe jetzt nichts großartig getrunken, ich habe nichts großartig gegessen.
Jetzt muss ich jetzt mal nebenbei machen und da erkläre ich euch mal was wir heute vor
haben und zwar im letzten Stream oder besser gesagt in einem, in einem der letzten Streams,
ich weiß nicht mal wann, ich glaube es könnte der letzte gewesen sein, bin ich ganz sicher.
Da hat zumindest einer gefragt, wie man sowas hier macht, gut wir nehmen ein Ubuntu Server,
wir machen kein DVD, wir machen Ubuntu draus. Hat einer sowas hier gefragt, wie man ein Cloud
Server installiert mit voll verschlüsselter Festplatte und das ganze dann auch wieder
entschlüsseln kann. Also er meint damit nicht entschlüsseln, sondern er meint damit freigeben.
Ja es ist ja folgendermaßen, wenn ich einen Linux Server installiere, der komplett verschlüsselt
ist, dann muss ich beim booten ein Passwort eingeben. Ohne Passwort beim booten kann die
Festplatte nicht entschlüsselt werden und dann das Betriebssystem nicht gestartet werden.
Ist ja irgendwo klar, wenn das ganze Ding verschlüsselt ist. Äh was auch immer. Und das waren wir
heute. Ich weiß nicht wer es gefragt hat. Es könnte der Skillkiller gewesen sein, als
ich den Namen gerade sehe, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich weiß, ich hätte mir
aufschreiben sollen wer es gefragt hat, ich habe keine Ahnung wer es gefragt hat. Und
da habe ich mir gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee. Das können wir heute mal im Stream machen.
Weil das ist gar nicht so einfach, wie es auf den ersten Blick aussehen mag. Ja. Denn,
nämlich dazu sagen. Ich muss mal kurz hier was schreiben. Du hast, hast du wirklich gefragt
oder gebadest du mich jetzt? Weil man weiß ja beim Chat, beim Twitch Chat weiß man, weiß
man ja nie. So, ähm, zumindest. Wir machen es ein bisschen komplizierter, als es bei
den meisten Cloud Anbietern ist. Ich weiß, jetzt kommt jeder, ich habe gefragt. Nein,
ich war es. Ich, excellent Chat. Ich, ich erstmal kurz ein Stück Pizza Leute. Der Chat.
Äh Pizza mit Waspela. Angeblich Pepperoni Wurst, aber das ist stinknormales Salami.
Also ich sehe da, ich sag mal Salami offiziell ist es Pepperoni Wurst, Peper Fett, Sardellen
und Pilze. Es könnte aber auch, ne, ha, ich hab's durchschaut. Es ist Salami, Pepperoni
Wurst, Sardellen und Pilze. Excellent. Ich weiß, viele mögen Sardellen auf der Pizza,
richtig? Chat, bei euch gibt's nur French Pizza oder
wie? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die sowas haben. Das Beste. Sardellen, Sardellen auf der Pizza,
das Ganze wird nur noch getoppt, das Ganze wird nur noch getoppt durch Bacon, Hähnchen,
Soß Hollandaise Pizza. Das toppt das Ganze noch. Das Ding ist aber halt salzig wie Sau,
deswegen muss ich jetzt erstmal hier 250 jährigen Rotweiner beitrinken. Ah exquisite, ah yes.
Werdig zu sein ist es einfach nur Wasser mit Saft.
Verastugierige Pilze. Die einzige Pilze, die ich nicht mag, ist das zum Trinken. Pilze
sind exzellent. Machen wir die Festplatte noch im Raid 1? Das können wir machen, weil
ich mir da nicht sicher bin, ob das der Installer out of the box kann. Ne, das machen wir nicht,
das kostet extra. Ich erzähle euch jetzt erstmal was wir genau vorhaben und dann erzähle
ich euch, wie ich es machen würde. Und dann sage ich euch auch noch, dass ich das nicht
im Stream mache, wie ich es machen würde, weil ich will die wirklich Low-Budget-High-Brain-Variante,
also ich will kein extra Volume machen. Oh super Joe. Also da, hallo ich habe ein Anliegen
und zwar schleichen hier Leute rum, wohnst du in der WG oder? Die die Temperatur des
Kühlschranks immer verstellen. Wie kann ich am günstigsten den Regler bzw. die Temperatur
bewachen als kleines IoT-Projekt? Da habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht
Super Joe. Also wir werden das ganze übrigens heute einmal mit Digital Ocean machen und
mit Hetzner Cloud oder je nachdem wie ihr wollt, mal gucken. Hoffentlich Terraform,
das stelle ich mir schwierig vor mit Terraform, weil wir müssen über die Serverkonsole was
machen. Also lasst mal überlegen, wie kann man das machen? Ja, das ist auch das erste
woran ich gedacht habe, allerdings überlege ich mir gerade, wie man das mit der Stromversorgung
macht. Naja, wenn der Kühlschrank in der Küche steht, ist es ja kein Problem USB-Strom
anzuschließen oder? Mit Batterie geht es theoretisch auch, aber es ist nicht wirklich
schön. Hast du Strom in der Nähe für USB oder ist alles belegt? Also die einfachste
Variante wäre folgendes, DS Temperature Sensor, das da, so ein Ding, das wäre das
mit Abstand einfachste. So ein Ding wäre mit Abstand am einfachsten. Das hier vorne ist
ein Temperatursensor, das Ding ist wasserdicht, zugelassen bis, frag mich nicht, minus 50
plus 50, keine Ahnung, müssen wir mal schauen, bis wann hin der Sensor, aber das ist glaube
ich kein Großart. Hier, hier, minus 55 plus 125 Grad. Ich behaupte mal, das reicht für
deinen Kühlschrank, um das ganze auszuprobieren. Und die Dinger sind auch sehr günstig. Kaufst
der, würde ich bei Amazon kaufen, da kannst du auch Prime bestellen, brauchst keinen Versand,
kannst du auch gleich einen Fünferpack kaufen, falls du noch mehr machen willst. Fünferpack,
einer Pack, was auch immer, bezahlste 2 bis 10 Euro für. So einen habe ich auch im Fischteich
hinten hängen, die Dinger funktionieren relativ gut. Die sind bis zu 2 Meter lang, jetzt mal
gucken wir nach dir, wie lang das hier ist, Kabellänge 100 Zentimeter. Und was du damit
machst, ist folgendes, das ist total simpel, einfach an die Pins von einem ESP32, oder
von einem ESP62 Pappen. Das ist total, also das ist ja wirklich simpel. So und dann musst
du nur noch gucken, dass du von deinem ESP32 regelmäßig die Werte irgendwo hin schickst.
Doch, doch, den Fischteich gibt es noch, den Fischteich gibt es noch. Ich habe das bei
mir im Fischteich hinten hängen, damit ich gucken kann, wenn es so kalt wird, dass ich
zudecken muss, nicht das Gefriertene am Platz nehmen, das Becken. Deswegen habe ich hinten
auch sowas liegen, aber mit Batterie. Ja wie gesagt, das ist relativ simpel, ESP32, ESP
66, Sensor dran, in den Kühlschrank gesteckt, wenn du irgendwie eine Öffnung hast da drin.
Und dann musst du gucken, dass du die Werte irgendwo hin schickst. Am besten wäre natürlich
über irgendwie MQTT, HTTP, ist eigentlich vollkommen egal, vielleicht noch mit einem
schönen Grafana Frontend zum auswerten, dann hast du sowas ähnliches, wie ich für meine
Heizung, hast du dann für den Kühlschrank. Ja ich habe hier Wassertemperatur und sowas
könntest du dir auch für deinen Kühlschrank machen. Musst du halt gucken, dass das Ding
einmal die Minute oder so oder alle, eigentlich wenn es am Strom dran ist, ist es egal, kannst
du auch alle 5 Sekunden, das sind ja alle 5 Sekunden, dass du das überträgst und gut
ist. Wenn du willst, können wir sowas mal im Stream machen. Wer wollte das noch mal hier?
Schreibe ich ihm auf, jetzt können wir im Stream machen, das ist eigentlich kein großartiges
Problem. Da platzen die Fische, hier wenn das friert, da platzen nicht die Fische, die
sind unten irgendwie, die juckt das nicht, da platzt das Becken, die Fische platzen nicht.
Ich schreibe mir jetzt auch immer mal auf, wer das Ganze vorgeschlagen hat. Alle 100
Millisekunden, das kommt, ich weiß nicht, wie der Sensor das verkraftet, keine Ahnung,
es gibt ja ein paar Sensoren, die mögen das nicht so, wenn sie permanent abgefragt werden,
keine Ahnung, wie es mit dem ist. So, zumindest das Fisch, ja die Fisch-KI, die ist bei Minusgraden
letztlich vorbei. Also so würde ich das machen. Sonst noch Fragen, Super Joe 741. Gartensensor
mit Temperatur, gibt es auch, gibt es auch. So, also, was wir heute machen, ist folgendes,
heute ist richtig der Hackermann-Action. Aber ist das Kabel nicht hinderlich, wenn man das
durch die Dichtung legt? Irgendwie musst du ja einen Temperatursensor, irgendwie musst
du ja einen Temperatursensor in den Kühlschrank kriegen. Oder hast du Stromanschluss im Kühlschrank?
Na, also vielleicht kannst du dir irgendwas von den Lampen abzapfen oder so, keine Ahnung,
ich hab mir noch nie Gedanken über eine Stromversorgung im Kühlschrank gemacht und ich bin mir auch
nicht sicher, wie gut WLAN aus dem Kühlschrank rauskommt. Müsste gehen, müsste gehen, wahrscheinlich
jetzt nicht das allergeilste Signal, aber müsste wahrscheinlich gehen. Wenn du in irgendeiner
Art und Weise eine Möglichkeit hast, eine Stromversorgung im Kühlschrank zu machen,
dann wäre das die bessere Variante vielleicht. Und wenn du es wirklich in Kühlschrank machen
willst, dann ist halt die Frage, ob man es nicht mit Akku macht, dann wird es aber etwas
komplizierter mit Akku. Weil mit Akku bedeutet das, du kannst kein normales 0-15-ESP32-ESP866-Board
nehmen, sondern du brauchst eins, mit Low Power Deep Sleep, also die meisten verbrauchen viel
zu viel Strom im Deep Sleep für Akkubetrieb, also dann musst du dir einen Fire Beetle ESP32
oder sowas holen, der ist ein bisschen teurer, nicht viel, aber ein bisschen teurer. Und
dann musst du dich mit Deep Sleep auseinandersetzen, dann müsstest du es so machen, dass das alle
Stunde einmal aufwacht oder ab alle zwei Stunden einmal aufwacht und dann den Status schickt.
Weil das ist nicht so schön, also mit Stromversorgung ist es deutlich einfacher. Ja, das kommt
auch noch zu, also mit Stromversorgung ist es deutlich einfacher. Vielleicht ist es
besser, vielleicht ist es besser, wenn du ein dünnes USB-Kabel durch den Kühlschrank
machst, keine Ahnung. Allerdings, die Sensoren sind dafür ausgelegt, auch im Wasser zu hängen,
deswegen ist das nicht so das Problem. So, also, während ich jetzt hier nochmal mein
nächstes Pizzastück futtere, erkläre ich euch, was wir heute vorhaben. Genau, Strom
vom Licht abgreifen, habe ich mir auch schon gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was das ist. Was
Kühlschranklicht hat, 12 Volt, ich habe ehrlich gesagt legit keinen Plassen Schimmer, das
könnte man sicherlich irgendwie machen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich da einmal mit Kühlschrank
herum wussten würde, ehrlich gesagt. So, also zumindest, zumindest was wir heute vorhaben,
grob beschrieben hat das ja hier das Skiller, ich habe Skillkiller, Skillkiller hat das ja
letztens geschrieben, also er besteht zumindest darauf, dass er das war. Hoffen wir mal, dass
das stimmt, sonst wurden wir hier mit der Hardcore. So, und er hat das letzte Mal nämlich
im Stream gefragt, wie man das machen kann, dass man ein Ubuntu Server Remote installiert
auf der Cloud, in der Cloud hat er gefragt, ich habe das hier nicht richtig kopiert, mit
Vollverschlüsselung von der Festplatte. So, und wenn die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt
wird, dann wie man das ganze freigeben kann, ohne dass man sich jedes Mal über die Konsole
verbinden muss. Das ist erstaunlich kompliziert, ich hätte das selbst nicht gedacht, dass
das so kompliziert ist. Prinzipiell ist es einfach sowas zu machen, also wenn man einen
eigenen Server hat, ist das überhaupt kein Problem, dann installiert man da, was weiß
ich, irgendein x-beliebiges Ubuntu über USB Stick, wählt im Installer Encryption aus
und installiert einen SSH Server zum freigeben und gut ist. Haben wir sogar schon mal im Stream
gemacht, ist ziemlich einfach, aber die Sache ist die, einfach mal so einen Ubuntu ISO einlegen
und installieren, machen die meisten Cloud Anbieter nicht mit. Digital Ocean und Hetzner
ist da, also gerade Digital Ocean ist da eigentlich besser, da kann man relativ viel machen. Hetzner
hat ziemlich viele ISOs, ich zeige euch das ganze mal. Wir legen jetzt einfach mal irgendeinen
Server an, also entweder, wo wollen wir hin Leute? Wo soll unsere Kiste stehen? Nuremberg,
Falkenstein oder Helsinki, wo wollen wir hin? Die Finn, die Finn brauchen Geld, oder? Oder
wie sieht es in Finnland aktuell so aus? Nach Burgstehude, das wäre es noch. Wir machen
jetzt, bei Montana Black gibt es jetzt einen Server hier. Moment, ah, Moment, wie schaltet
man den Crap nochmal aus? Sekunde. Okay, also, wir nehmen den Server in Burgstehude, okay?
Ich hoffe, dass die Webseite kackt nicht ab. Ich hoffe, die Webseite kackt jetzt nicht
ab, weil das irgendwas checkt oder so. Richtige Hacker-Mans wieder am Start, ne? Also Server
in Burgstehude, da nehmen wir Ubuntu 20.04. So, und die Sache ist jetzt die, ich zeige
euch das mal, wir installieren das ganze. Also, die Kosten dieses Streams sind durch
Prime-Sub schon gut abgedeckt, weil man sieht hier, der billigste Server kostet 289 im Monat
beziehungsweise 0,5 Cent die Stunde. Vielleicht geht jetzt auch jemand von Hetzer los, installiert
den Burgstehude und den Server. Na, mal abfahren. Warum nicht? Gebrauchen könnte ich das ja
bestimmt immer. So, will ich mal mein Essasaki aussorten? Jetzt zeige ich euch mal, warum
das in der Cloud schwieriger ist, als man eigentlich so meinen mag. So, erstellen wir
den Server mal. Das ist quasi eine VM, ja. Das ist quasi eine VM. Oh, es ist doch nicht
in Burgstehude, fuck, you baited. Moment, mal ist es das, was ich denke, ich weiß nicht,
was du denkst. Was denkst du denn? Big brain Gedanken vom Chat? IP League, OMG IP League.
Ja, naja, grüner Grauser, wir machen das jetzt selbst, weil das ja die Cloud-Anbieter
nicht anbieten, logischerweise. Die können ja nicht für dich deinen Server mit deinem
Key verschlüsseln. Das machen wir jetzt von Hand. Um jetzt mal das, was ich am Anfang
sagen wollte, den Gedankengang zu vollenden. Exzellent, Satz. Das Problem ist, dass die
meisten Cloud-Anbieter, die haben ein paar Betriebssysteme zur Auswahl und Custom-ISOs
ist jetzt nicht so viel. Also Custom-ISOs geht bei den meisten Cloud-Anbietern gar nicht,
also ich kann nicht einfach hier einen, wie gesagt, bei den meisten Ausnahmen gibt es,
ich kann hier nicht einfach einen ISO-Image mit einem aktuellen Ubuntu hochladen und
das dann über die Konsole installieren, geschweigele die Konsole kann das auch nicht mounten und
sonst wie. So, bei Hetzna ist es ein bisschen besser. Hetzna hat jede Menge Sachen zur
Auswahl, also man könnte jetzt hier drüber zum Beispiel sich einen Ubuntu 20.04 von
Hand installieren, aber das wollen wir ja nicht. Die Challenge bei der ganzen Sache
ist ja, um die es hier ja ging, ist, dass wir oder das ist das, was ich mir noch so
auferlegt habe und dass es ein bisschen komplizierter wird und auch irgendwie ein bisschen interessanter
wird und vielleicht auch übertragbar ist auf mehr Cloud-Anbietern, dass wir keinen
Rescue-Mode verwenden und keine ISO-Images vom Provider, sondern wir wollen komplett
selbst installieren. Komplett. So und das ist ein bisschen komplizierter, weil wir haben
zwar ein Betriebssystem, worauf wir uns connecten können, ich zeige euch das mal, äh, vielleicht
muss ich erstmal, oh Chat, Chat, ich muss euch mal kurz ausblenden, ich muss mal was
gucken. Nicht, dass ich aus Versehen Sachen leake, das wollen wir ja nicht, na. Monka
leake. Wir gucken einfach nicht hin. Exzellent. Siehste, siehste, gut, dass ich euch ausgemacht
habe, gut, dass ich euch ausgemacht habe, weil ich gerade einfach mal mein Passport
geleakt habe. Und zwar im Clipboard-Manager. Lull. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt erstmal den
Kram wieder ausschalten. Ich dachte mir nämlich schon, da habe ich nicht aufgepasst. Das
wollte ich jetzt gerade mal die History löschen vor meinem Clipboard-Manager. Und dann kann
ich euch wieder anmachen. Na ja, ihr kennt ja das Login-User, ihr kennt ja das User,
den Usernamen nicht dazu, also der unmittelbar passiert weder nichts, außerdem wisst ihr
eh, außerdem wisst ihr eh, dass man Passport 123456 ist, also das ist jetzt so schwierig,
na. Wie gesagt, Passport ist eh 123456. Root, Root ist das Passport. Ok, ich kann euch,
ich kann euch wieder einschalten, ist gut, ich mache euch wieder an. So, sehr schön.
Ah, jetzt ist das Passport nicht mehr, nicht mehr leaked. Passport entleaked. Vielleicht
ist auch der Name der Katze und hier hat das Passport, hat er nicht gespeichert. Wunderbar.
So, können wir das Ganze mal anmachen. So, natürlich durch das Ganze hin und her bin
ich jetzt eh, gerade voll vom Faden abgekommen. Also genau, ich wollte mich einloggen auf
der Kiste. So, und damit ich euch jetzt mal kurz bevor wir anfangen verdeutlichen kann,
warum das Ganze nicht so einfach ist, wenn wir uns da jetzt mal verbinden auf den Hetzner
Server, by the way, ohne Passport nur mit meinem SSH Key, das heißt ihr habt da, good
luck, ja. Ich frage mich nur, wie man beim booten den Encryption Key eingibt. Ja, das
war mal alles jetzt im Stream. Wie gesagt, das eigentliche ist gar nicht so schwierig,
problem schwierig ist das Betriebssystem zu installieren. So, also was wir, das einzige,
was wir verwenden können ist das vorgefertigt installierte Betriebssystem vom Provider.
Das heißt, irgendwie müssen wir es jetzt schaffen dort ein eigenes Ubuntu Image drauf
zu bekommen. Nein, das stimmt noch gar nicht. Wir müssen dort den Ubuntu Installer gelauncht
bekommen und damit dann das Provider Betriebssystem überschreiben und im Installer machen wir
dann die Vollverschlüsselung von der Platte mit einem Custom Key und wenn wir das drauf
haben, dann machen wir Unlock PSSH. So, und dementsprechend ist das relativ kompliziert.
Platte ist nämlich die. Wir haben eine Festplatte, das war's. Wir haben keine Möglichkeit ISUS
zu mounten. Wir haben keine, also die Custom ISUS zu mounten, die erhalten bleiben bei
einem Reboot. Der Provider kann absolut nichts mit Festplatten anfangen. Man muss allerdings
sagen, die Provider machen das meistens von sich aus schon. Ist das vom Provider überhaupt
überlaubt, dass man das vorinstalliert überschreibt? Klar, warum nicht. Die bieten das ja sogar
selbst an in dem Fall, aber wir benutzen das ja nicht. So, jetzt heißt, jetzt muss man,
ich hab mir das im Vorfeld natürlich schon ein bisschen überlegt. Also ich bin jetzt
jetzt da komplett planlos, planlos am Start. Es gibt zwei Varianten. Warum muss es denn
unbedingt ohne ISO sein? Wie willst du sonst dein Betriebssystem installieren? Oder was
meinste? Also wir gehen jetzt ja mal von aus, der Provider bietet nicht das an, was wir
haben wollen und wir wollen das selbst installieren. In dem Fall bei Hetzner ist es ganz gut.
Hetzner hat 30.000 Sachen zur Auswahl, da ist es kein Problem. Aber wir gehen jetzt
mal von aus, sagen wir mal, wir wollen die neuste Ubuntu Beta probieren. 20.10, nur mal
theoretisch und 20.10 wird von Hetzner nicht angeboten. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriegen
wir 20.10 bei Hetzner drauf? Man kann keine Custom ISUS hochladen, geht nicht. Über die
Konsole, die es hier gibt, die brauchen wir übrigens gleich, über die Konsole kann man
auch kein Custom ISO mounten. Macht das einen großen Unterschied zwischen Ubuntu und Debian?
Nö, nur dass mir persönlich Ubuntu besser gefällt. Aber Ubuntu ist mehr oder weniger
ein Debian. Einzige was mir bei Ubuntu auf den Keks geht, ist die Sache mit der Jaml
Netzwerk-Config. Ja Leute, wie oft noch IP liegt. Goodluck, Herr Pfannen. So, also wie
ich es machen würde, wenn ich sowas selbst betreiben müsste, dann würde ich ein bisschen
Geld in die Hand nehmen, mit Custom Volume dranhängen, das Custom Volume verschlüsseln
und dort meine sensiblen Daten drauflegen. So würde ich das in der Cloud machen, ich
würde gar keine Vollverschlüsselung vom System machen. Kostet aber extra, kostet aber
extra, also ein bisschen was. Ich weiß nicht was es hier kostet. 10 GB kostet 46 Cent
im Monat. Vielleicht will das jemand nicht haben, ich weiß es nicht. Aber so würde
ich es machen, wenn ich es wirklich auch betreiben müsste und möchte, dass das easy zu verwalten
ist. Hat nämlich noch den Vorteil, hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass man hier auch unabhängig
Backup machen kann. Sowas ist eigentlich die schönere Variante, aber das machen wir ja
heute nicht. Das machen wir heute nicht. Das Einzige, was ich mache, ich esse noch mal
ein Video. So und jetzt könnt ihr euch aussuchen, mit was wir es zuerst machen wollen. Wollen
wir zuerst eine Digital Ocean vor allem machen? Oder wollen wir es gleich bei Hetzner machen?
Ich kann euch sagen, folgende Schwierigkeitsverteilung. Digital Ocean relativ einfach, Hetzner ziemlich
kompliziert, weil die nicht mitspielen wie ich will. Prinzipiell, wenn ich auf einer
Cloud Kiste was eigenes installieren möchte, würde ich das immer hiermit probieren. Weiß
ich, ob ihr das kennt? Netboot XYZ, immer die Hardcore Variante. Okay, he doesn't know,
he lacks critical information. Nein, in dem Fall nicht. In dem Fall habe ich mir da schon
mal Gedanken darüber gemacht. Wenn ich net installen was machen würde, würde ich immer
das hier nehmen. Das ist ein Boot, oder es ist nicht wirklich ein Bootloader. Es ist
ein Boot Image, was weitere Images laden kann. Also das, ich kann Netzwerkboot machen, Netboot
XYZ und in dem Menü habe ich dann zur Auswahl, was ich installieren würde. Ich zeige euch
mal wie das Ganze aussieht, aber ich kann euch gleich sagen, wir können das leider
bei Hetzner Cloud nicht verwenden, weil, und jetzt passt mal auf, wenn mir irgendeiner
von euch erklärt, wie das Netzwerk technisch funktioniert, dann bin ich beeindruckt, Chet.
Ihr müsst mir das mal erklären. Ich weiß, wie es funktioniert mittlerweile, also IP
Adresse ist folgende. Das ist meine IP. Was mich schon mal wundert ist, Slash 32. Das
ist das erste, was mich gewundert hat. So, das ist meine Public IP. Die funktioniert
hier auch offensichtlich, weil ich bin hier auf dem Server drauf. Oh, ich muss mal kurz
das wichtigste erst mal installieren. Sekunde, gleich, ganz wichtig. Das muss jetzt mal kurz
sein. Ja, auf, mach. Angeblich ist eine SSD drin. Ah, yes. So, jetzt müssen wir erst mal
den Zug drüber fahren lassen. Ist da eine Festplatte drin? Dann ist mal digital ausschneidende
SSD drin. Gut, so, jetzt haben wir eine Runde Monka DB Monka DB. Ich hab ein Stück von meiner
Pizza wieder gegessen. Jetzt kann man weitermachen. Chet, wer mir erklärt, wie das funktioniert,
der gewinnt einen Sub. Und wenn er schon einen Sub hat, überlege ich mir irgendwas anderes.
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber, wer mir erklären kann, wie das funktioniert, der
ist echt Big Brain. Der gewinnt den Big Brain Award für den Stream. Meine IP vom Server
ist das hier. Subnetz slash 32. Schon mal komisch. Mein Gateway ist das da. Wie funktioniert
das Netzwerk technisch? Wie kann ich mit dieser IP dieses Gateway verwenden? Und, wohlgemerkt,
es funktioniert. Wie geht das? Er gibt eigentlich keinen Sinn. Für alle, die sich jetzt fragen,
was will der Max von mir, diese IP-Adresse mit diesem Netz, also nein, diese IP-Adresse
in diesem Netz liegt nicht im Netz vom Gateway. Das ist quasi so, wie wenn ihr daheim 192.168.0.1
hättet als IP von eurem Rechner und euer Router hätte eine ganz andere IP. Euer Router
hätte 10.5.5.5. War ganz billig gesagt. Also sprich, ihr kommt überhaupt nicht zu eurem
Gateway. Wie funktioniert das? Wer kann mir erklären, wie das funktioniert? Das ist nicht
duelst der Gleit. Es ist übelst, es ist übelst, es sind auch keine VLANs. Nutt, nee auch nicht.
Es ist ein Feature, was ich so noch bei keinem anderen Anbieter gesehen habe. Die werden
behält sein per Nutt umgeleitet. Kann ja sein, kann ja sein, aber Fakt ist, netzwerktechnisch
ist es so, ich habe diese IP anliegen auf meinem Interface und das als Gateway. So,
ich sehe, ihr habt genauso wenig Ahnung wie ich auch am Anfang. Ich werde euch zeigen,
wie das funktioniert. Zwar. Oh nee, wo waren die Leases von DHCP? Ach du Scheiße. Wird
irgendwie über die Mac geroutet? Nee. List, Leases, ich kann mir nicht merken, wo der Kram
ist. Ja. Valib, DHCP, Leases, nee. Ach fuck, ich habe vergessen, wo die Leases sind. Nein.
Ubuntu, Leases, File, DHCPd, nee DHCPcd. Deadlift, du hast noch Zeit, du hast noch Zeit. Schau
doch mal in Interfaces nach, wie die Kiste konfiguriert ist. DHCP, komplett DHCP. Ich
bin jetzt total hängen geblieben. Wo steht das Scheiß dann? Also, wenn ich das File finde,
kann ich euch zeigen, ich habe vergessen, wo die Leases stehen. Ich kann es euch aber
erklären. Total bescheuert, wo steht denn der Kram?
Netzwerkmanager braucht keiner. Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht Netzwerkmanager. Okay.
Okay, es ist ziemlich kacke, ich finde nicht mehr, wo der ganze Kram steht. Ich hätte
schwören können, es steht unter Valib, DHCP, aber irgendwie steht da nichts. Zumindest,
es funktioniert folgendermaßen, es ist doof, dass ich euch das nicht zeigen kann. Nein,
es ist kein Netzwerkmanager, es ist auch kein Resolve-Con. Wo stand der Scheiß dann? Äh.
Ja, genau, da gucke ich doch die ganze Zeit schon. Es ist auch nicht Bridge-Mode. Ich
wollte euch das jetzt im DHCP-File zeigen, weil da habe ich gestern auch gefunden. Und
man erkennt, man denkt sich erstmal, what the fuck ist das? Okay, warte mal, da hast
eigentlich recht. Wir suchen einfach mal danach. Wir suchen mal nach, ich weiß, dass ich das
selbst festlegen kann. Ich will euch zeigen, warum das überhaupt funktioniert. Ich weiß,
wie ich das anders machen kann. Wo wo ich dann dieses kacke File liess. Weil ihr seht
ja auch, das ganze geht über DHCP. Oder in dem Fall hier über System D, Gedöns. Und
das Dumme ist, ich habe es ja gestern gefunden. Es hieß irgendwas mit Lease. Fuck, wo ist
das denn? Ja, das haben wir alles schon ausprobiert. Ja, und da ist es nicht. Zumindest, die benutzen
ich, ich erkläre, ich erzähle euch jetzt einfach, wo es ist. Ich erzähle euch jetzt
einfach, da ist einfach nichts drin. Normalerweise liegt der Scheiß immer da. Ich erzähle euch
jetzt einfach, was die machen. Ich weiß, dass ich gestern nach dem DNS-Sauber gesucht
habe, den man per DHCP kriegt. Es nervt mich jetzt, dass ich euch das nicht zeigen kann,
weil das sowas abgedreht ist. Ich weiß aber, nach was ich creppen kann. Ich weiß aber,
dass ich euch das nicht zeigen kann. Ja, da. Irgendwo hier, da sind wir richtig. Hier sind
wir richtig irgendwo. Irgendwo hier. Zumindest, was die verwenden ist, was die verwenden ist,
was ganz furchtbar ausgefallen ist, was ich so noch nirgendswo gesehen habe. Die verwenden
ein ganz abgedrehtes Feature, was ich noch nirgendswo gesehen habe. Oder habe ich mir
das mit einem anderen Befehl angeguckt gestern. Und zwar verwenden die folgendes. Passt mal
auf. RFC3442 static route DHCP. Hab ich im Leben noch nicht gehört. Verwendet keiner,
den ich kenne. Also, wenn es interessiert, das hier ist das RFC-Dokument dazu. Und zwar,
was die machen, ist folgendes. Die pushen per DHCP neben der externen IP, also neben
der hier, pushen die eine statische Route, die außerhalb von dem Netz hier liegt, die
alle anderen Routen überschreibt als die Fault Gateway. Hab ich noch nirgendswo anders gesehen.
Hab ich noch nirgendswo gesehen. Es wird alles per DHCP konfiguriert, aber mit einer Option,
die niemand verwendet, den ich je gesehen habe bisher. Deswegen ist es doof, dass ich euch
mein Lease-File nicht zeigen kann. Ich habe es gestern gefunden, jetzt finde ich es gerade
aus irgendwelchen Gründen gerade nicht. Also Massive Big Brain, was die da treiben. So,
und deswegen funktioniert die Geschichte mit Netboot nicht, weil Netboot, ich zeige euch
mal wie das eigentlich aussieht mit Netboot. Netboot wird gestartet entweder über ein
Crop oder ein USB Stick oder sonst was und bootet dann in so ein Menü hier und von dort
kann man auswählen, was man noch als nächstes installieren will. So, und die Sache ist die
Netboot kann keine DHCP RFC 3442 Static Routes, Routes, Huts, was auch immer. Genau, RFC, vielleicht
habe ich da gestern reingeguckt, kann das sein, in die kleinen Conf. Ja, also so ein Kram verwenden
die hier. Im Leben noch nicht gesehen und keine Ahnung was mit denen los ist. Zumindest Netboot
kann das ganze nicht. Ich zeige euch mal wie das mit Netboot aussieht, weil Netboot ist
eigentlich eine absolute Big Brain Geschichte. Wir nehmen jetzt mal hier das aktuelle Netboot
ISO, das kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, der mal einen Server neu installieren möchte,
mit Netzwerk install, Netboot, das ist das einfachste was es gibt, das kann man über
PXE machen, das kann man teilweise aus dem PXE, IPXE von der Netzwerkkarte starten,
das kann man über ein Crop selber starten, man kann seinen Crop überschreiben und Netboot
rein machen. Ich zeige euch mal kurz wie das aussieht, wenn man es dann verwendet. Wir
starten jetzt mal in der Testweise in der VM, wo man das sieht. Und dann starten wir es
einfach nur, dass ihr es mal gesehen habt, wie das ganze ausschaut. Das ist nämlich
meine erste Anlaufstelle, immer wenn ich in der Cloud irgendwas selbst installieren will,
einfach Netboot drauf machen und gut essen. Äh, ein Printer raus, close. Also Leute, ihr
habt alle falsch gelegen mit wie die es angeblich machen, die machen es komplett über DHCP,
aber auf die abgedrehteste Art und Weise, wie man es per DHCP machen kann. So, Netboot,
hallo? Oh, ok, warum war immer das jetzt hängen? So, wenn man Netboot übers Netzwerk bootet,
dann sieht das normalerweise so aus. Guckt, Netboot, bla bla bla. Das könnte man auch
bei Hetzner in der Cloud machen. Configuring TCP IP, Network, bla bla bla. Genauso würde
das bei Hetzner auch machen, das funktioniert auch bis hierhin. Bis hierhin funktioniert
es. Ähm, was nicht mehr funktioniert ist der nächste Schritt, nämlich, dass der sich
zu Netboot XYZ verbindet und dieses Bootmenü hier holt. Das geht in der Hetzner Cloud
nicht, weil IPXE, zumindest das was Netboot XYZ verwendet, unterstützt kein, ich muss
abgucken, weil ich schon wieder vergessen habe wie es heißt, unterstützt leider kein
RFC3442 classless static routes über DHCP. Exzellent, alles klar. Ich hoffe man konnte
mir folgen chat. Da haben sich bei Hetzner gedacht, Big Brain, gute Idee das so zu machen,
das heißt die einfachste Variante, das hier funktioniert nicht. Guckt man nämlich wie
einfach das ist, den Netboot XYZ. Jetzt einfach hinsagt, Linux Network installs, Ubuntu 20.04
install, er lädt das neuste Ubuntu ISO runter im RAM, bootet das ganze Ding und der Installer
läuft. So einfach könnte es sein, nur, dass es bei Hetzner nicht funktioniert. Also ihr
sehts wie schön das Tool ist. Ich kann euch nur empfehlen das zu verwenden, wenn ihr mal
irgendwo anders seid als bei Hetzner. Control habt ihr den Ubuntu Installer, total easy.
Leider geht das nicht. So und da habe ich mir gestern echt lange Gedanken zu gemacht,
wie man das, wie man Hetzner austricksen kann, dass man einen eigenen Custom Ubuntu ISO installieren
kann. So und jetzt haltet euch fest, ich bin auf folgende Idee gekommen. Wie findet er
dann, wie findet der dann den Router, wenn der Server nicht im selben Netz steht. Ich
vermute mal, so wie das normalerweise auch funktioniert, der wird einfach in ein Uprequest
schicken, who has, was auch immer, ohne Netmask und der Router antwortet. Wenn man es genau
wissen will, muss man sich mal die RFC durchlesen, ich hab das nicht gemacht, ich hab ehrlich
gesagt keine Ahnung, wie es genau funktioniert. So und ich hab mir jetzt folgendes überlegt,
was wir ausprobieren werden. Und zwar, jetzt big brain, big brain, mal gucken, ob das alles
so funktioniert. Was wir machen werden ist folgendes. Wohlgemerkt nochmal, was das Ganze
so schwierig macht ist, ich kann kein Custom ISO hochladen bei Hetzner, ich kann da kein
USB Stick oder so dranhängen, ich kann kein Custom ISO in der Konsole auswählen. Das
einzige, was ich habe ist eine Disk, eine Festplatte, SDA, mehr hab ich nicht auf dem System und
ich muss es jetzt irgendwie schaffen, den Ubuntu Installer, da sieht man nämlich, dass
sich da die Katzbüssel in der Schwanz beißt, sagt man das oder so, oder die Henne, die
Huhn und das Ei, das einzige Laufwerk, wo ich was drauf speichern kann, ist meine Festplatte.
So, wenn ich jetzt allerdings den Ubuntu Installer von meiner Festplatte aus starte, dann kann
ich ja im Ubuntu Installer die Festplatte nicht überschreiben, weil da liegt ja das
ISO drauf. Versteht man das Problem, was es gibt bei der ganzen Geschichte? Ich kann
euch auch gleich zeigen, die Lösung ist nicht so schwierig. Das heißt, was wir jetzt machen
muss ist, was wir jetzt machen muss ist, richtig, nee, nee, nicht partitionieren, ich will im
Ubuntu Installer komplett sagen können, use komplette Platte, mach dein Encryption Magic
und fertig. Also, die Festplatte wird komplett gewiped vom Installer oder komplett neu partitioniert.
Das heißt, was ich jetzt probieren werde ist folgendes. Ich lade mir das Ubuntu Installer
ISO runter auf die Festplatte. So, also das gibt's hier. Ja doch, choose my name, so ungefähr
machen wir das, so ungefähr machen wir das. Wir werden das im RAM machen, aber wie gesagt,
es ist nicht so einfach, wie es auf den ersten Blick aussieht. Also, wir laden uns jetzt
das ISO runter. Das ist das Server Install Image, der Klassik Installer vom Ubuntu Server.
Wir laden das runter. So, und die Schwierigkeit ist jetzt, wir müssen den Server dazu bringen,
von diesem ISO zu starten. Das ISO liegt aber auf unserer Festplatte. Das heißt, wir müssen
jetzt erstmal im Grub einen neuen Bootloader-Eintrag machen, der auf dieses ISO zeigt. Ich hab
mir das zum Copy Pasten im Vorfeld schon fertig gemacht. Ja, das will ich, das wollte ich
jetzt nicht im Stream. Oh, fuck. Falsches ISO. Ja, ARM und AMD 64 liegt sich ja auch
so ähnlich. Guck mal, da ist noch kaum Unterschied. Lest das mal hier. ARM 64, AMD 64, sieht doch
wirklich fast gleich aus. So, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt einen neuen Grub-Eintrag machen
von Hand. Dann müssen wir den Server neu starten. Dann müssen wir das im Grub auswählen, dass
wir von diesem ISO starten wollen. Schön ins Hut verzeichnen, ja, da ist es im Grub
später einfacher zu finden. Dass wir von diesem ISO starten wollen. Wenn wir dann von
diesem ISO gebootet sind, dann kommen wir in den Ubuntu Installer. Das Problem dabei
ist, dass der Ubuntu Installer slash-cd-rom erwartet, wo seine Daten liegen. Und das Server
hat kein fucking slash-cd-rom. Und da ist auch nichts dran, was du als slash-cd-rom
mounten kannst. Das heißt, wir müssen dann, während der Installer, also wir laden das
ISO über Grub in den RAM, und dann tauschen wir on the fly, während, ich hab mir das gestern
schon angeguckt, ja, aber das ist echt Big-Brain-Methode. Und andere Cloud-Anbieter wie Hetzler brauchen
das garantiert auch nicht so kompliziert. Wir tauschen dann on the fly, während der Installer
booted von hier in RAM. Dann tauschen wir on the fly das Installer ISO aus, nämlich wir
dann mounten das von der Platte und downloaden und kopieren uns das in die RAM-Disk und mounten
das ISO in der RAM-Disk und das slash-cd-rom, dass der Installer denkt, wir haben eine CD
oder einen USB-Stick eingesteckt. Und dann müssen wir noch die Netzwerk-Config von Hand
machen, weil die Netzwerk-Config im Installer auch nicht funktioniert. Ich hoffe, man hat
alles verstanden, oder? Ah, yes, excellent. Marz2009, nein, und zwar verwenden die etwas,
das sich RFC3442 Classless Static Roots nennt für DHCP. Was das macht ist, wenn du deine
DHCP-Adresse abrufst, pusht das eine IP als dein Gateway, der auch außerhalb von deinem
Netz liegen kann und der überschreibt alle anderen Default-Routes. Das geht normalerweise
gar nicht. Das geht wahrscheinlich nur, wenn Support eingebaut ist in dem jeweiligen DHCP-Kline
und im Betriebssystem. Und ist anscheinend. Ich kenne keinen anderen Hostler, ich kenne
niemand, der diese Sache sonst verwendet. Das Einzige, was ich dazu gefunden habe, ist,
dass es das gibt, aber niemand empfiehlt es zu verwenden. Wie gesagt, mit Digital Ocean
ist das deutlich einfacher. Das nächste Mal machen wir das noch in der Magenta Cloud.
Ich wollte schon immer mal Magenta Cloud benutzen. Also, ich hoffe, ich habe das jetzt gut genug
erklärt. Das werden wir jetzt ausprobieren. So, was ich gemacht habe ist, ich habe mir
jetzt schon mal das aktuelle Ubuntu ISO runtergeladen. Das nennen wir jetzt mal um. Einfach nur in
Ubuntu ISO. Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen. Würde das bei Windows einfacher funktionieren?
Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte keinen Platz im Schema, wie ich das mit Windows machen sollte. Ne,
ich glaube das komplette Gegenteil wäre der Fall. Ich würde Windows, weil mir die Kenntnisse
dafür fehlen, so auf diese Art und Weise nicht installiert bekommen.
Ich hoffe, die Musik ist nicht zu laut. Ups. So, also, wir sind immer noch auf unserer
Hetzner Kiste. Jetzt legen wir mal los. Ich habe mir das, ich wusste, bis der Zug vorbei
ist, der lässt sich nicht abbrechen. Ich habe mir das aktuelle Ubuntu ISO hier hinkopiert.
Wir können gucken, was haben wir? Okay. Wir haben eine Festplatte. SDA1, die hat unser
root-Fallsystem auf der ersten Partition. Und dann haben wir noch auf SDA1 haben wir
noch ein BIOS-Boot-Partition und EFI-Boot-Partition. Also, warum auch immer das 14 und 15 ist,
wahrscheinlich weil das ganz hinten ist, was auch immer. Zumindest hier liegt das ISO
letztendlich drauf unter slashroot-ubuntu.iso. Hey Max, kam gerade rein. Was hast du bis
jetzt gemacht? Ich habe eine VM angelegt in der Hetzner Cloud und bin gerade drauf eingeloggt.
Du hast noch nichts verpasst. Und ich habe einen Ubuntu Installer ISO runtergeladen hier
nach slashroot. Also, nee, nicht nach slashroot, nach slash, also nach root. So, und jetzt
kommt der Big Brain Move, Leute. Haltet euch fest. Da habe ich gestern echt ein bisschen
danach gesucht, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Und zwar, man kann Custom-Crup Entries machen
und zwar unter etc-crup-d-40-custom. Da steht noch nix drin. Crup ist der Boot-Manager.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie das Ganze normalerweise aussieht. Vielleicht haben es die ein oder
andere nicht gesehen. Ich reboote mal. Normalerweise sieht das Ganze so aus. Ups, ich war zu langsam.
So, so sieht das normalerweise aus hier. So sieht das normalerweise aus. Das ist der
Boot-Manager. Da kann man beispielsweise auch irgendein Rescue-CD starten und sowas. Rescue-Mode
von Ubuntu. Und hier kann man jetzt, hier fügen wir jetzt einen extra Eintrag hinzu,
über den wir das ISO booten können. Aber erst mal das normale Ubuntu wieder starten,
dass man weitermachen kann. Das heißt, wir manipulieren jetzt den Bootloader von dem
Ding, dass wir einen eigenen Eintrag bekommen. Scheint zu gehen. Bist du einer dieser 4Chan-Hacker?
Ja, wer braucht schon 4Chan? Ich bin ja Twitch-Hacker-Mans. Viel, viel Advanced da mittlerweile. Twitch-Streamer
sind die wahren Hacker-Mans. 3Chan, 5Chan. Gibt es auch 5Chan, wenn es 5Head gibt? So,
ok. Also, hier liegt mein ISO. Und jetzt kommt der big brain move. Etc-crop-40-custom. Und
da müssen wir jetzt einen eigenen Boot-Menü-Eintrag machen. So, und zwar menu-entry. Ich kann
das übrigens copy-paste. Ich muss das eigentlich gar nicht schreiben. Menu-entry-ubuntu-install.
Ich copy-paste die einzelnen Zeilen und sag dann was zu. Das ist wie das Ding den Boot-Manager
heißt. So. Dann müssen wir folgendes reinschreiben. Das da. Ich rücke mal ein bisschen ein. Was
das macht ist, das ist ein bisschen, das ist schonmal Emacs. Ja, habe ich nur eine ganze
Weile benutzt. Das ist eine Abkürzung. Und zwar, der sagt ihm jetzt, er soll unter dem
aktuellen Filesystem, was hier eingehängt ist, ein Ubuntu ISO nehmen. Und das später
als Root verwenden, wenn er davon bootet. Das kann man auch alles von Hand machen. Wenn
man das von Hand macht, müsste man hier sowas machen wie set-root. Und dann müsste man ihm
sagen Festplatte 0, Partition 1 und sowas in der Richtung. Ja, das macht das hier für
einen. So. Natürlich kann man das ISO nicht direkt verwenden, sondern, wie das unter Linux
üblich ist, wenn man ein ISO mounten will, das geht ja, kann ich auch so auf der Kommandozeile
machen. Also sprich, ich kann ein ISO einhängen unter irgendeinem Pfad. Dann geht das über
ein sogenanntes Loopback Device. Das heißt, das ist das nächste was ich machen muss.
Dieses Ubuntu ISO, was der da gefunden hat, soll er als mit, what the fuck, Loopback Device
einhängen. Und jetzt kommt die Magic. Jetzt kommt die Magic. Da habe ich gestern ein bisschen
gebraucht, bis ich das raus gekriegt habe. Also. Trick 17. Was der jetzt macht ist, der
mountet sich das Ubuntu. Wohlgemerkt, wir reden hier nicht von vollständigen Linux,
wir reden hier von einem Bootmanager. Von einem Bootmanager, der eigentlich nur dafür
da ist Sachen zu booten. So. Chat, muss ich nicht erklären was das macht, oder? Ist vollkommen
selbstverständlich, glaube ich. Muss man nicht erklären, oder? Eigentlich, eigentlich
voll klar. Kann ich Link posten? Ja. So. Was das macht, ist folgendes. Der hier sucht
das Ubuntu ISO. Der hier mountet das Ubuntu ISO. Was das hier sagt ist, das ist der Startparameter,
was er machen soll. Das hier ist die Anweisung für den Bootloader, was er machen soll. Und
zwar, er soll auf das Loopback Device gehen, das ist dort wo mein ISO eingehängt ist.
Was? Kekega? Oh, das ist dumm, das will ich nicht. Nein, das will ich nicht. Da bleiben
wir beim Original. Da bleiben wir beim Original, Pepega. Ich habe für euch schon Pogo reingemacht.
So. Das heißt, er geht jetzt auf das ISO. Dort im Ordner install gibt es einen vmlinux,
das ist quasi der Mini-Kernel zum starten. Weiß nicht, ob man das so richtig beschreiben
kann. So, und jetzt geben wir folgende Bootoptionen ein. Das hier ist erstmal wurscht. Das hier
ist das wichtige, dass er das Linux, was in diesem ISO drinnen steckt, in RAM lädt. Das
ist ein Ubuntu-spezifischer Bootparameter. Und das ist, dass er dann auch wirklich bootet.
Das haben wir jetzt im CRUB hinzugefügt. Jetzt müssen wir noch den CRUB updaten. Und
jetzt kann ich rebooten. Jetzt passt mal auf, was da passiert. Wenn ich jetzt in die Konsole
gucke, dann war ich zu langsam, da muss ich nochmal neu starten. Jetzt haben wir hier
einen Eintrag Ubuntu install. Mit dem ganzen Zeug, was wir hier eben eingetragen haben.
Und diesen Eintrag kann ich jetzt starten. Und es sieht erstmal genauso aus, aber ihr
werdet feststellen, es ist was anderes. Und zwar, es ist der Ubuntu Installer. Das heißt,
wir haben ein ISO auf meiner Festplatte liegen. Das ISO haben wir über den CRUB gemountet
und das Ubuntu in diesem ISO in RAM gebootet. Also gebootet und das komplette in RAM geladen.
Das ist mal big brain, oder? So, jetzt haben wir nur ein Problem. Ich werde euch das Problem
mal zeigen und dann was man dagegen macht. Language, Englisch, alles gut. Wir sind nicht
in Kokona. Wir sind in Europe. Germany. Ist ja wie Netboot für Arme, genau. Das Problem
ist nur, dass Netboot nicht geht. Wegen RFC, Blablub, Static, was auch immer, Routing,
keine Ahnung. Lokal, ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal, wo das Problem ist. Detect Keyboard
Layout, jawoll, wir wollen deutsches Keyboard haben. Wir haben kein Baguette Keyboard, alles
klar, passt. So, und jetzt gibt es ein Problem. Jetzt versucht er nämlich auf den USB Stick
bzw. auf das CD Laufwerk zuzugreifen. Es ist egal, ob es ein CD Laufwerk oder ein USB
Stick ist. Und zwar sucht er jetzt die Dateien zum installieren. Die Dateien zum installieren
findet er nicht, weil der Ubuntu Installer auf das ISO scheißt. Das ist ihm egal. Und
wir können das ISO von der Platte auch nicht verwenden, weil wir die Platte jetzt gleich
platt machen wollen. Das heißt, jetzt kommt der nächste Big Brain Schritt. Wir gehen in
die Installer Konsole. What the fuck? Alter, Nvidia. Wo kann man das hier umlegen? Keyboard
Shortcuts. Photocraft the Scene. Ja, genau. Kann man das löschen? Nein, weg. Ah ja, und
F1 muss ich auch löschen. So, warum hijackt das einfach mal in die Shortcuts? So, jetzt
kommt Big Brain Schritt Nummer 2. Wir gehen in die Installer Konsole. Da ist man normalerweise
auch relativ selten unterwegs. So, und was wir jetzt machen ist, wir wissen ja, dass
wir das ISO auf der Festplatte liegen haben. Wir können die Festplatte aber nicht verwenden,
weil wir die Festplatte gleich mit dem Installer überschreiben wollen. Das bedeutet, ich
muss mir jetzt mal temporär die Festplatte mounten und das ISO in RAM kopieren und danach
das ISO, was im RAM liegt, und das Slash CD-ROM mounten, dass der Installer weitergeht.
Soweit klar? So, ich weiß, ich hab DEV SDA, das ist meine Platte, die im System drin ist
und die mounten wir jetzt einfach mal. Gehen wir mal Slash MNT, gucken wir hin und sehen,
das ist unser normal installiertes Ubuntu auf der Festplatte. Was wir haben, wir sehen
auch hier unser Ubuntu ISO. Das heißt, wir kopieren jetzt das Ubuntu ISO in die RAM-Disk.
Also, jetzt haben wir die Ubuntu ISO auf unser Installer-System in RAM kopiert. Wir können
mal gucken, wie viel freien RAM wir haben, also das passt schon. Jetzt, nächstes Schritt
ist eigentlich noch eine Runde mehr Big Brain, weil unter Slash CD-ROM erwartet, wie man
hier sieht, der Installer erwartet unter Slash CD-ROM das, was gemountet ist, um die Installation
von dort machen zu können. Das heißt, das muss ich jetzt von Hand machen. So, und das
heißt, jetzt mounte ich das ISO aus dem RAM, was ich mir gerade kopiert hab, ach übrigens
by the way, ich muss die alte Festplatte wieder unmounten, weil sonst geht der Installer ja
später nicht drüber und kann sie neu formatieren. Das heißt, jetzt mounte ich das ISO auf Slash
CD-ROM. So, und nachdem man den ISO nicht so einfach mounten kann, das wäre nämlich
auch zu einfach, und unmounten schon mal gar nicht, äh, mounten. Oh, Moment. Man kann
den ISO ohne Parameter mounten, ist das neu? Huge! Man muss keine, man muss kein Geschiss
mehr angeben für ISOs, ja das ist ja geil. Also, bis zur letzten Ubuntu-Version musste
man noch ein riesenlanges Geschwubbel hinten angeben, und zwar, hier sowas musste man sonst
immer machen, mount, minus O, loopback, read only, minus T, ISO 9660 und dann das ISO-File,
das muss man anscheinend gar nicht mehr, ok, gut zu wissen. So, Installer, retry. Äh,
ach so, jaja, jaja, continue. So, hat funktioniert. Slash CD-ROM ist gemountet, nein, ist nicht,
hä? Moment. Also ich weiß, dass es funktioniert, weil ich hab's ausprobiert, ich glaube ich
bin nur beim falschen Schritt gerade. Äh, es kann sein, dass man den Kram doch mit angeben
muss, ich probier's mal an, mount, CD-ROM. Hä? What the? Ok, ok, ok. Mount, gehen wir
den Installer. Load Installer Components for Media, wow, wow, wow. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht
sicher, ob ich das in der richtigen Reihenfolge gemacht hab. Ah, jetzt funktioniert's, ok.
Äh, jetzt kann er aufs CD-Laufwerk zugreifen, und zwar, das ging nur, weil wir das selbst
gemountet haben unter Slash CD-ROM. So, was nicht funktioniert ist, der Installer geht
jetzt, ich kann schon mal spoilern, beim nächsten Schritt geht der Installer nochmal kaputt,
und zwar, weil das Netzwerk nicht konfiguriert werden kann. Das Netzwerk kann nicht konfiguriert
werden, weil Hetzner diese komische Geschichte mit, äh, wie hieß es, dateless, RFC-Rooting
Videos macht. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt an der Stelle sagen, do not configure network.
Es bringt auch nix für den Installer, das Netzwerk irgendwie von Hand zu konfigurieren
oder so. Ähm, nicht dateless, classless hieß es, äh, funktioniert nicht. Ah, der Bildschirmarbeiter,
nice. Warst du auch schon mal bei Hetzner in Books the Hude im Rechenzentrum? So, also
wir sagen jetzt erstmal, wir wollen das Netzwerk nicht konfigurieren. So. Äh, wie nennen
wir den Server? Cute, Cute-Server. So, neuer Name für User, aber Max. So, jetzt vergebe
ich mal ein Passwort, das werde ich euch nicht zeigen, weil das brauche ich nachher zum Einloggen
und das ist auch ausreichend lang. So, jetzt macht er erstmal seine Magic und installiert
ein bisschen und jetzt fragt er mich gleich, wie ich die Festplatte formatieren will und
die Festplatte partitionieren will und jetzt kommt der eigentliche Schritt, wenn man das
ganze verschlüsseln will. Wie gesagt, die ganze Vorarbeit hier war jetzt nur nötig,
weil ich erstens nicht das ISO mounten wollte, was Hetzner anbietet und weil, ähm, weil
ich ein eigenes ISO verwenden wollte, was von der Festplatte geladen wird ohne Zusatzvolumen.
Das heißt, jetzt kommt die eigentliche Geschichte, wenn man den Server verschlüsseln will. Man
muss im Installer das hier auswählen, Use Entire Disk and Setup Encrypted LVM. Jetzt
sieht man auch, warum es wichtig war, dass ich das ISO umkopiert habe, weil wäre das
ISO noch gemountet von der Festplatte, dann könnte ich jetzt ja an der Stelle nicht die
Festplatte komplett neu partitionieren und neu einrichten lassen und komplett verschlüsseln,
weil dann das ISO ja noch drauf liegen würde. Was wir jetzt ja gemacht haben ist, wir haben
nur von der Festplatte gebootet das ISO, ähm, und dann das ISO ersetzt durch einen ISO im
RAM und darüber installieren wir jetzt. So, also, Use Entire Disk. Musst du dann nicht
die DHCP-Geschichte noch rüber kopieren. Doch, das mache ich nach der Installation,
der macht ja eh nicht viel, der macht ja eh nicht viel. So. Ähm, wir lassen ihn erstmal
seine Installer, seine Installer-Magic machen. So. Und nachdem wir jetzt das Ubuntu installieren,
ohne Netzwerkverbindung, macht er ein paar Sachen nicht. Ist das ein VPS, ist die Hetzner
Cloud? Ja, das ist im Prinzip, das ist im Prinzip eine, eine VM in der Cloud, ja. So,
Encryption Passphrase, Excellent Password 123456. Da nehmt ihr natürlich irgendwas gescheites,
weil ansonsten könnt ihr euch das gleich sparen. Yes. Das ist sowas hier. Das ist ne, ich würde
sagen KVM, VM ist das. So, jetzt fragt er uns wieviel Speicherplatz darf er verwenden
von der Festplatte alles. Und jetzt darf er neu installieren. So, nachdem wir jetzt den
Ubuntu Installer laufen lassen haben, ähm, äh, QEMO und KVM ist mehr oder weniger das,
also nein, ist es nicht das gleiche, aber KVM verwendet Treiber von QEMO. Also, wenn
du QEMO siehst, ist es zu 99% KVM. Ähm, so, nachdem wir den Ubuntu Installer jetzt laufen
lassen haben, ohne Netzwerkverbindung, macht das ein paar Sachen nicht, die wir dann gleich
anschließend von Hand machen müssen. Äh, muss man bei Festplattenverschlüsselung dann
jedes Mal beim Boot das Passwort eingeben oder kann man das automatisieren? Naja, wenn
du das automatisieren könntest, dann könntest du dir das mit dem Passwort ja sparen. Ah,
also. Wo ist der Sinn der Verschlüsselung, wenn das Passwort im Klartext quasi lesbar
dran steht? Du musst dich aber nicht, und das machen wir danach noch, du musst dich nicht
danach per Konsole verbinden, sondern das kannst du auch über SSH machen. Das ist ja grad
der Knackpunkt dabei, warum man das, äh, recht bequem sogar machen kann. So. Write
Changes to Disk, yes. So, und wir müssen dann abschließend noch ein paar Sachen machen,
weil, wie gesagt, wir installieren das jetzt ja von der Disk, ohne Netzwerkverbindung,
wenn man Netzwerkverbindung hat, macht Ubuntu ein bisschen Magic, mehr Magic während der
Installation und man muss ein paar Sachen nicht von Hand machen. Und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen, das ISO, das ISO-File, was wir jetzt im RAM liegen haben, am Ende der Installation
noch mal auf das fertig installierte System zu kopieren, weil, wohlgemerkt, wir haben
ja immer noch kein USB-Stick dran hängen und wir haben grad keine Netzwerkverbindung,
das bedeutet, ich kann mit Abt danach keine Software nachinstallieren, weil ich keine
Internetverbindung hab, die richtig funktioniert, erstmal, und, ähm, kein ISO habe, von dem
ich nachinstallieren kann. Das heißt, ich müsste dann erstmal von Hand über die Serverkonsole
eine Abt-Sources-List eintippen, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Deswegen machen wir das
anders und kopieren das ISO drauf. Speichelst du auf dem Server die Penta-Nuke von Rambo?
Ne, die hab ich hier noch irgendwo, die kommt nicht auf den Server, das ist zu kritisch,
zu kritisches Material. Ich hab auch noch die, ähm, Quad-Nuke, wo, ich hab's vergessen,
die wem geklaut hat. War das der Cheater? Was spricht denn für das Setup anstelle einer
Hetzner ISO? Weil, es muss so unterscheiden. Gegen eine Hetzner ISO und von dort manuelles
Setup spricht gar nichts. Sofern Hetzner das Betriebssystem anbietet, was man installieren
will. Wir haben das jetzt ja hier für den theoretischen Fall mal gemacht, dass man beispielsweise
in Ubuntu, Beta, keine Ahnung, 20.10 installieren will, was sie noch nicht haben. Ähm, und
Hetzner ISO selbst, was die für einen installieren, können wir nicht verwenden, weil wenn wir
das Hetzner ISO verwenden, können wir ja keine Vollverschlüsselung von der Systemplatte
machen, weil es schon fertig installiert wird. So, Configure Package Manager, kann da nichts
machen, großartig. Select den Install Software, funktioniert auch nicht, weil, äh, keine
Internetverbindung. Das heißt, bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig, wie den Bootloader
zu installieren. Und das ist jetzt der kritische Punkt. Wenn das fehlt, schlägt, bootet das
ganze Ding später nicht. Das heißt, da muss man jetzt ein bisschen, okay, ist schon fertig.
So, und jetzt wichtig, bevor, bevor wir das neu starten, bevor wir das neu starten, gehen
wir nochmal auf die Konsole und sehen, hier, guck, unter slash target ist unser neues
Betriebssystem eingehängt. Wir kopieren jetzt die Ubuntu ISO nochmal nach slash target.
Du kannst das ISO doch einbinden oder manuell, nein, kann ich nicht. Hetzner erlaubt keine
Custom ISOs. Die haben ein vorgefertigtes Set an ISOs, die sie zur Verfügung stellen,
wenn das nicht dabei ist, was du haben möchtest, hast du gelitten. Und dann bleibt dir nichts
anderes übrig, als das, um so Umwege zu machen. So, jetzt haben wir das Ubuntu ISO nochmal
rüber kopiert, weil das brauchen wir gleich zum installieren. Gehen wir zurück, Installer
ist fertig, yes, achso, er installiert noch Crap, okay, davor machen, sonst kann er nicht
booten. System ist set to OTC, ja, alles klar, mach. Jetzt legt er die Crap-Einträge an,
dass das System auch booten kann. Das heißt auch, dass der Server nicht 24-7 aktiv ist.
Lasst mich nicht fragen, was die Leute damit machen, keine Ahnung. Ich mach das jetzt
für die Installation, danach schmeißt das Ding wieder weg. Aber klar, doch natürlich
bringt die Vollverschlüsselung, was auch wenn der Server aktiv ist. Weil spätestens
wenn du einmal Stromlos machst, ist das Ding unwiederbringlich kaputt, als sei denn du
hast das Passwort. So, Installation complete, continue. So, das heißt jetzt müssen wir
ein bisschen Post-Jam machen und gucken, ob es bootet. Ähm, Matze, das ist einfach so
historisch, denke ich, die sind meistens installant drin. By the way, ich weiß, dass
es nicht funktioniert. Doch, es funktioniert, man sieht es bloß nicht. Ich muss jetzt ein
paar Mal hier spammen, in den Crap gehen und damit hat nämlich die Hetzener Remote-Konsole
irgendwelche Probleme. Quiet und Splash raus machen, dann bootet es auch. Guck da. So,
und wir sehen, vollverschlüsselte Festplatte, please unlock disk. Das heißt, das System
bootet nicht weiter, bis ich das Passwort eingetippt habe. Der nächste Schritt ist jetzt,
dass wir erstmal gucken, dass der Crap, dass es standardmäßig ordentlich rebooted und
danach, wie wir das ganze Remote entschlüsseln können. Weil niemand möchte sich zum Reboot
sein des Servers erstmal auf, bei Hetzener verbinden, auf die Management-Konsole verbinden
und da ein Passwort eintippen. Quiet ist, dass er nichts ausgibt und Splash ist, dass
er ein Bootlogo anzeigt. So, also, unlock 123456, Big Brain, Passwort. Oder unlock die Festplatte,
wo das System startet und irgendwann ist der Server da. Zack, Q-Server. So, jetzt müssen
wir uns hier einmal einloggen, weil wir haben noch keine Netzwerkverbindung. Jetzt müssen
wir uns wieder einmal einloggen, weil wir haben noch keine Netzwerkverbindung. Guck,
ist down. Das heißt, ich muss mir jetzt einmal einen DHCP-Client nehmen und, ähm, ja, sudo
und eine Netzwerkverbindung ziehen. Und ziehe da, äh, und ziehe da, wir haben ein IP.
Das heißt, ich gehe jetzt rüber und log mich auch da drauf. Ach so, ha, ich hab's
noch großartig erzählt, Leute. Ich hab's noch großartig erzählt, was wir machen müssen.
Bei der Minimal-Installation ist kein SSH-Server dabei. Die haben doch Custom-ISOs, ist das
da nicht dabei? Doch, 20.04 ist dabei. Die Custom-ISO ist, also, in dem Fall könntest
du das, das ist das, was ich am Anfang gesagt hab, das könntest du auch bei Hetzer machen.
Über das, über das Custom-O und doch, doch. Wobei du ein paar Sachen trotzdem von Hand
machen musst, weil die Installation auch mit dem Custom-ISO nicht problemlos durchläuft.
Es war ja grad der Witz, das nicht da drüber zu machen, falls das im Betriebssystem nicht
angeboten wird. Könnte die Installation ersetzt werden von jemanden ohne deinem Wissen, sodass
du das Passwort eingibst und dieses abgegriffen wird? Nein. Oder? Doch. Oder? Ich glaube schon,
weil der SSH-Server, den du benutzt zum Anlocken später, der liegt ja unverschlüsselt drauf.
Und da könnte sich jemand wahrscheinlich den Private Key kopieren vom SSH-Server, dann
würdest du nicht merken, dass er das ausgetauscht hat. Doch, wahrscheinlich würde das funktionieren,
bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht ganz sicher ehrlich gesagt. Aber viel wichtiger ist erstmal,
dass er keinen Zugriff auf deine Daten hat. Ja, austricksen könnte dich da einer. Da
müsste er aber erstmal Zugriff zum Server bekommen, also sprich, der müsste dort ins
Rechenzentrum oder der Provider müsste das machen. So, jetzt ist das Problem, es ist
kein SSH-Server, also sprich, der Server ist oben, hat auch eine IP, aber ich kann mich
nicht darauf verbinden, weil ich keinen SSH habe. So, und ihr werdet sehen, wenn ich versuche
Abt-Update zu machen, sagt er, oh fuck, funktioniert nicht, weil keine Sources angegeben sind.
Guck, etc, Abt-Sources, da steht nur das CD-ROM drin, keine Internet-Sources. Das heißt,
deswegen ist der Grund, warum ich mir das ISO hier nochmal hinkopiert habe. Das heißt,
ich kann jetzt das ISO nochmal mounten, und zwar nach Media-CD-ROM, und jetzt kann ich
einen Abt-Install-SS, nee, Open-SSH-Server machen, und nachdem das drin ist, dann kann
ich mich auch einloggen. Der hat sich jetzt die DHCP-Config aus dem Herzennetz gezogen,
doch, doch, funktioniert. Kein Problem, dass das funktioniert. Das funktioniert ganz normal
jetzt. So, und nun komme ich da auch per SSH drauf. Ja, äh, also, nachdem ich mal alles
gelöscht habe hier, komme ich da auch drauf. So, alle, übrigens nicht per Route, sondern
per Max mit dem User, den ich während der Installation angelegt habe, wenn ich das Passwort
richtig eingib. Und jetzt bin ich auf meinem Server drauf. Das heißt, das nächste, was
ich jetzt machen muss, ist, ich will ja, ich will ja, dass ich hier Abt-Update und Geduldens
machen kann. Das heißt, ich unmounte erstmal wieder das ISO. Das ISO brauchen wir jetzt
nicht mehr. Das ISO war nur, war nur notwendig, damit ich ähm, den SSH nachinstallieren kann.
Irgendwoher muss er das ganze ja bekommen. Wann kommt man wieder YouTube-Content? Eventuell
das Wochenende. Ich habe eine Idee für ein Video, aber ihr kennt mich, kann durchaus
sein, dass es nicht kommt. So, was ich jetzt machen muss, ist, eine ordentliche Sources-List
eintragen. Ja, gut. Aber es hat irgendwie Ei. Wir schmeißen das CD-Laufwerk raus und suchen
uns eine Sources-List, und zwar am besten die offizielle Sources-List, dass ich dann
auch mit Abt-Sachen nachinstallieren kann. Zack. Monka. Eww. Set. Paste. Weiß ich, was
ich jetzt hier für Schmerzen gerade wieder hatte. Aber weg damit. So, und jetzt kann
ich sagen, Abt-Update und zack. Es ist da. Es funktioniert. Was ist denn Sudo als Admin?
Das ist, dass er sich 15 Minuten speichert, dass du Sudo werden kannst. Also, du kannst
15 Minuten lang glaube ich, oder standardmäßig 15 Minuten werden. Du kannst sicher 15 Minuten
lang Sudo werden, und dass du jedes Mal das Passwort eingeben musst. So, Abt-Update.
Also, wir sehen Ubuntu Server integriert. Eine Sache sollten wir jetzt noch machen,
dass das ein richtiger echter Ubuntu Server ist. Und zwar, wir sollten das Ding hier mal
installieren. Das ist nämlich das, was Ubuntu normalerweise auch während der Installation
nach, während der Installation macht, wenn man eine Netzwerkverbindung hat. Der sagt
nämlich, okay, es ist ein SSH Server und ein Basic Ubuntu Server. Das macht der unter
der Haube. Das seht ihr nicht. Das könnt ihr, doch, klar seht ihr das. Das könnt ihr
im Installer auswählen. Aber das macht der nur, wenn er eine Netzwerkverbindung hat.
Und hatte er nicht, deswegen müssen wir das jetzt von Hand machen. Und wir werden sehen,
er installiert noch einige Sachen nach. Das ist jetzt wirklich schon ganz minimal, minimalst
der Minimalsysteme, die der uns da von der CD installiert hat.
So und wir suchen jetzt mal den Hetzner Guide. Dass er dann nämlich nach dem Boot sich automatisch
was zieht.
Und zwar müssen wir das hier machen, nachdem wir installiert haben, dass er sich nach jedem
Reboot eine DHCP Adresse zieht.
Was ist mit Remote Unlock im Titel gemeint? Also wir haben die Festplatte verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, du musst jetzt jedes Mal beim Rebooten das Passwort eingeben von deiner
Festplatte, dass das Betriebssystem gestartet werden kann. Und das Passwort musst du aktuell
noch eingeben über die Hetzner Konsole. Und das ist ziemlich unpraktikabel. Deswegen
werden wir es jetzt so machen, dass du das auch Remote Unlocken kannst mit einem Passwort,
ohne die Hetzner Konsole zu verwenden.
Heute wieder Progress, fast. So in der Richtung. So, jetzt ist gleich der Ubuntu Server ein
richtig echter Ubuntu Server. Geht auch ZFS als Root Verschlüsselung für ein VPS mit
Remote Unlock. Ja. Das ist mit Remote Unlocking kompatibel, das habe ich selbst schon gemacht.
Das haben wir sogar schon mal im Stream gemacht. Das haben wir vor 2 oder 3 Jahren, ewig her
haben wir das mal im Stream gemacht. ZFS Encryption Unlocking. Da war das noch Beta.
So, erstmal ein paar wichtige Tools. Ist schon alles installiert. Ok, also wir haben jetzt
den Ubuntu Server. Die Hetzner Server Konsole ist glaube ich VNC. So, also wir haben jetzt
eine Custom Ubuntu Server Installation gemacht. SSH installiert, User angelegt. Kannst du
eine Bit.tfs ausprobieren? Ja, aber jetzt nicht hier drauf. So, was jetzt noch fehlt
ist, also wir machen jetzt erstmal ein Reboot und testen, ob alles funktioniert. Wir machen
Update und dann gucken wir, ob alles funktioniert. So, danach machen wir ein Reboot und dann
könnt ihr sehen, dass alles funktioniert außer man muss halt immer noch das Passwort eingeben
beim Rebooten. Und das werden wir jetzt lösen. Nach dem Reboot. Erstmal machen wir ein Update
und gucken, dass alles funktioniert und dass ihr seht, dass das ein vollwertiger, stinknormaler
Ubuntu Server ist, den wir installiert haben. Auf dem jetzt auch alles funktioniert, was
man so erwarten würde. Der macht jetzt ein bisschen Kernel Update, ein bisschen Paket Update
und alle möglichen Sachen, die er so braucht. Dann machen wir hier noch das mit der Netzwerk
Config und dann ist die Installation fertig. Da müssen wir uns nur noch darum kümmern,
dass wir das Remote anlocken können per SSH. Das machen wir nach dem Reboot. Und ich warte
jetzt eigentlich nur, bis der Kram fertig ist. Nun wir das mit neun Monaten. Exzellenz
Subscription, Dankeschön. Schockt keinen mehr, verständlich. Chat ist schon abgehärtet.
Startet eigentlich SSH bevor die Festplatte verschlüsselt wurde? Entschlüsselt wurde?
Nein, normalerweise nicht. Deswegen installieren wir jetzt noch einen zusätzlichen SSH Server,
der vor dem Entschlüsseln der Festplatte gestartet wird, nur für das Entschlüsseln der Festplatte
läuft. Also im Prinzip ein SSH Server, der nur dafür da ist, dass ich ein Passwort eingeben
kann über SSH. Oh, der könnte mal seine Updates, auf ne eigene Partition, nö. Der kommt in,
der kommt, ja doch, doch, auf seine eigene Partition natürlich. Auf der Boot, Boot Partition,
die ist ja unverschlüsselt. Genau, ein SSH Server im Inet, ja, ja, genau. So machen wir
das jetzt. Wenn der denn irgendwann mal fertig mit Updates ist, wohlgemerkt. Ich werd schon
mal ne andere Sache zwischendurch machen und zwar SSH Copy, ich kopier schon mal mein Public
Key drauf, dass ich nicht in Zukunft so viel Passwörter eingeben muss. So. Oh, ich hab
mich vertippt. Gut, Key ist added. Sehr schön. Jetzt aktivier ich nur noch die Netzwerk-Config,
dass er sich immer ne neue IP zieht. So und übrigens den, wer braucht IPv6, lul. Da wär
ich jetzt wieder geflamed für, aber wir lassen das jetzt mal weg. Sollte ich einfach DHCP
IPv4 holen und gut ist. So und wenn wir jetzt rebooten, ENS3 stimmt, ja, ENS3 stimmt. Wenn
wir jetzt rebooten, haben wir nen vollwertigen Ubuntu Server. Einzige kleine Schönheitsfehler
jetzt halt noch, dass wir, oder dass er von uns beim Booten über die Konsole nen Passwort
haben will und das sackt. Oh, ich hab noch was vergessen, das müssen wir gleich machen.
Ich hab noch vergessen, dass der hier Splash und Quiet rausnehmen soll, das muss ich gleich
noch machen. So, jetzt sagt er uns, ok, tja, unlock immer deine Festplatte, das mach ich
und das werden wir jetzt gleich machen, dass wir das nicht mehr mit den Remote-Konsole
machen müssen. Aber vorher muss ich den Crap mal anpassen. So, da sind wir wieder. Ich
kann mich einloggen ohne Passwort, aber für Zudu brauch ich immer noch ein Passwort.
Moment, ich hab mich wieder vertippt. Etc, Defaults, Crap. Und da kann man jetzt anpassen,
dass der standardmäßig nicht Quiet und nicht Splash macht, also sprich, dass der Text ausgibt
beim Booten, dass er auch kein Boot-Bild anzeigt, sondern Text, was er gerade macht. Update,
Crap. So, jetzt passt das. Gut, und nun machen wir das, was ich gerade angekündigt hab, wir
sorgen dafür, dass man den Remote über SSH entsperren kann. Und das ist im Prinzip ziemlich
easy mittlerweile, man muss kaum noch was von Hand machen, man muss das hier installieren.
Wir installieren erstmal Bash-Auto-Vervollständigungen, weil ich keinen Bock hab, alles von Hand zu
tippen. So, Abt-Install. So, das Ding müssen wir installieren. Das ist ein SSH-Server,
der quasi ganz vereinfacht gesprochen, man kann nicht sagen, im Boot-Manager läuft,
das stimmt nicht, der aber quasi gestartet wird, noch bevor das eigentliche Betriebssystem
gestartet wird. Das ist quasi so ein Mini-Linux-Kernel, der vom Bootloader gestartet wird, der dann
das eigentliche Linux startet, der unter anderem Festplattenentschlüsselung macht und dort
kommt jetzt dieser SSH-Server rein. Und den brauch ich zu nichts anderem, außer für meine
verschlüsselte Festplatte zu unlocken. Ja, das funktioniert aber auch nur, solange die
Boot-Partition, weil ich es gerade im Chat seh, solange die Boot-Partition unverschlüsselt
ist. Aber das ist das normale Setup. Das ist das normale Setup. Wenn man wirklich alles
verschlüsselt, inklusive der Boot-Partition, dann muss man den Passwort von Hand eintippen.
Das geht gar nicht anders. Weil dann kann ja nichts mehr starten. Wobei mich nicht wundern
würde, wenn es dann nicht auch irgendwelche Tricks gäbe. Es geht alles irgendwie, ja.
So, und jetzt kommt der Schritt, wo vielleicht ein paar Probleme hatten, weil ich hab im
Chat vorhin welche gesehen, die haben gesagt, sie wussten nicht, wie man den Server-Remote
locken soll. Also, ihr müsst einmal das da installieren. Und jetzt müsst ihr nach ETC
da hingehen. Und da muss jetzt eine gültige Authorized-Key-File rein. Nämlich den Authorized-Key-File,
zu dem ihr halt einen Private-Key habt. Und Choose My Name hat recht, er zickt rum, aber
das kann man relativ einfach beheben. So, und ich kopiere dort jetzt mein Authorized-Key-File
rein, was ich hier bei meinem User liegen hab. Also dort, wo schon mal ein Key drin ist.
Und danach sag ich nochmal Update, nee, Update, was Update, RCD, minus K, minus U, minus
all? Nee, ach du Scheiße. Update in Ubuntu. Update in, ok. Fast. So, minus K, minus U all.
Nein, minus, minus, minus U, minus K all, minus U, minus K all, fast richtig. Äh nee,
auf unterschiedlichen Ports muss der nicht lauschen, weil der beendet sich, bevor der
andere gestartet wird. Der hat aber tatsächlich Probleme, weil es die gleiche IP ist, das
wirst du gleich sehen. So, was der jetzt macht ist, der baut ein neues Mini-Linux zusammen,
was vom Bootloader gebootet wird, was Festplattenentschlüsselung macht, was SSH macht und was dann das eigentliche
Linux bootet. Minus K ist, dass er das für alle Kernel-Versionen, die installiert sind,
macht und minus U ist, dass er es updatet. Also U muss man machen, was er machen soll,
also sprich er soll es updaten, minus K, dass er es für alle installierten Kernel-Versionen
macht. Man könnte ja auch das nur für das letzte machen wollen oder so, wenn man Angst
hat, man macht was kaputt. Ja, so und wenn er jetzt damit fertig ist, was jetzt nicht
mehr allzu lange dauern kann, dann kann ich rebooten, wegen Fingerpedia, man könnte unterschiedliche
Ports machen, ja. Aber das ist nicht schlimm, das lässt sich relativ easy beheben mit dem
Gemäckere. So und jetzt haben wir den, wenn ich jetzt reboote, dann werdet ihr sehen,
erstens der Crop, jetzt sieht man was, weil ich den Splash-Screen ausgeschaltet habe.
Habe ich übrigens ein Update-Crop gemacht, das machen wir vielleicht nochmal. Hi Happen,
10 Monate, dankeschön, exzellent. Big Brain-Subscription hier. Der IQ vom Chat ist mal wieder massiv
auf dem aufsteigenden Weg hier. So und ihr werdet sehen, dass der Crop jetzt was ausgibt
und dass der mich weiterhin nach einem Passwort auf der Konsole fragt, aber dass der auch
einen SSH-Server startet. Passt mal auf. Seht ihr es? Da hat jetzt ein SSH-Server gestartet
und per DHCP eine IP geholt und ich hab übrigens was vergessen. Ich hab was vergessen, es funktioniert
gar nicht. Oder vielleicht doch, mal gucken. SSH, nein es funktioniert nicht. Ich hab was
vergessen. Hat irgendjemand eine Idee was ich vergessen hab? Ich weiß das ist so eine
Oberlehrer-Frage. Wo lernt man sowas, wenn man das ein paar Jahre macht? Man kann übrigens
immer noch anlocken hier drüber. Guck, also anlocken über Konsole geht immer noch. Ich
hab was vergessen. Hat irgendjemand einen Plan was ich vergessen hab? Wahrscheinlich
nicht. Ich werd's euch verraten und zwar das DHCP und der SSH-Server, der jetzt fürs
Anlocken zuständig ist beim Booten, der kann diese extra Würste, was Hetzner beim DHCP
macht, auch nicht. Deswegen müssen wir dem erstmal beibringen, dass das Ganze funktioniert.
Und das macht man folgendes, da hab ich gestern einen guten Forumseintrag gefunden, der das
schon gemacht hat. Und zwar muss man dafür ein eigenes Startscript einbinden. Das ist
jetzt alles nur Hetznerspezifisch, was ich hier mach. Also, wenn ihr das selbst machen
wollt, einfach einen Server verschlüsseln, ist das easy as fuck. ISO rein, Ubuntu installieren,
Installer auswählen, Encryption installieren lassen, Job hier drauf, fertig. So, das ist
jetzt alles nur Hetznerspezifisch, weil die so komische Netzwerkgeschichten machen. So,
man braucht noch ein kleines Startscript, dass der nämlich diese tolle Config von Hetzner
einfügt, dass man sich überhaupt per Netzwerk verbinden kann. Toll, ne? So, das heißt,
ich geh jetzt, ich leg das File jetzt mal an. Wenn ich finde, wo das hin muss. Genau,
das ist richtig. Das lernt man, wenn man es mal braucht. Ich hab das gebraucht mit Remot
anlocken und seitdem hab ich mir als Umgefall gemerkt, wie es geht. Startup Script. Übrigens
bei Vim immer SetPaste machen, dann spackt er auch nicht rum, wenn man reincopypastet.
So. Jetzt müssen wir nochmal alles updaten und jetzt fügt er diese Startup Script ein
beim Booten und was das macht, ist folgendes, das hier oben ist erstmal egal. Der startet
Netzwerk. Der startet Netzwerk und dann fügt er diese Customrouten hinzu, die Hetzner braucht,
dass es funktioniert. Ohne funktioniert es bei Hetzner nicht. Das ist eine rein Hetzner
spezifische Geschichte. Ich hab das auch noch nie bei irgendeinem anderen Anbieter gesehen
und auch noch nie selbst benutzt diese Taktik. OV hab ich noch nicht verwendet, ne. Ich find's
aber über Azure schon echt kompliziert teilweise. Du musst in Azure auch, wenn du VMs in Azure
machst, wohlgemerkt, musst du auch auswählen, teilweise bis zum Standort vom Server Rack,
also bis zum Rechenzentrum für welches Server Rack, wie du Hochverfügbarkeit machen willst.
Das finde ich auch unnötig kompliziert, wie das in Azure gemacht ist. So. Und jetzt,
by the way, jetzt sollte es funktionieren, wenn ich es richtig gemacht hab. Reboot. Gucken
wir mal. Pause jampen. Leute, pause jampen. Hold it. Hold it. Pause jamp. Gucken wir,
ob es funktioniert. Starting drop here. Okay, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken,
mal gucken, ob ich es anpingen kann. Das ist schlecht. Das sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren.
Wonka Smoke. Ich hab garantiert irgendwas vergessen und ich weiß nicht, was. Fehlt
ihm die Ausführungsberechtigung? Na eigentlich. Den nicht, oder? Oh, dem fehlt die Ausführungsberechtigung.
Ha. Lul. Big brain chat. Chat ist wieder. Siehste, das geht nur durch die ganzen Prime
Subs. Ohne Prime Subs wäre der Chat low brain. Aber durch die ganzen Subs ist er high IQ und
kann mir sowas verraten. Ups. Richtig, dem fehlen die Ausführungsberechtigungen. Also
machen wir das Ganze nochmal. So, Moment, wo sind wir hier? 775, oder was hat der hier?
755. Static roots. Hab ich sonst noch irgendeinen Schritt vergessen? Guck nochmal drüber.
Guck mal hier, die haben auch Probleme damit. Doch, man braucht es immer noch. Update. Der
braucht nochmal Update, ja. Die Skripts, die hier liegen, die liegen einfach nur rum
und warten darauf eingebunden zu werden. Das einfachste der Sache zu umgehen ist natürlich
Chmod 777 slash. Chmod 777 minus R slash. Da hat man die Probleme alle nicht. Ist Vodafone
nicht. So, Chat, und jetzt sollte es funktionieren. Bless RNG, ach nee, das geht ja nicht mehr.
Was ist ein guter Ersatz für Bless RNG? Pray RNG, keine Ahnung. Ey, funktioniert deine Stream
Archive Seite nicht mehr? Das müssen wir mal den Sebaro fragen, die ist ja nicht von mir.
Archive. Das ist das alte Archive, was die ganze Zeit funktioniert hat. Das ist normal,
was das kaputt ist, das haben sie noch nicht fertig programmiert. Aber hier, das ist Google
Drive Archive, funktioniert noch. So, und jetzt Chat, Chat. Give Energy, Give Energy,
sonst kann ich nicht rebooten. Ich gifte mir selbst auch mal. Ich warte, kein Pok, Energy
muss gegiftet werden, sehr gut, sehr gut, okay. Und jetzt können wir die Poks holen,
jetzt können wir die Poks holen. Das sieht schon besser aus. Ha! Funktioniert. Ach so,
ja, und das ist das jetzt, was Choose my Name angesprochen hat. Der meckert jetzt, weil
der SSH Server sich geändert hat. Wir haben den SSH Server im laufenden Ubuntu, jetzt
dürfte er pokken, Leute, jetzt dürfte er pokken, ist okay. Ihr habt lang genug geholtet, jetzt
dürfte er pokken, jetzt ist er laufend. Unter der gleichen IP ist der SSH Server vom Ubuntu
und der SSH Server vom Boot Manager, bin ich gesagt. So, die einfachste Variante ist so,
Strict Hostkey Checking, no. Dann scheißt er nämlich. Ach so, und auch nicht als Max,
sondern als Root. Das ist keine allzu schöne Variante, das ist richtig, weil dann erkennt
man nicht, dass sich das Ganze geändert hat, aber hierfür soll es jetzt mal tun, Root.
So, und wir sind auf unserem Ubuntu Server drauf, aber nicht etwa im Betriebssystem
an sich, sondern in einem ganz kleinen Minimal-Environment, in dem ich eigentlich nichts anderes machen
kann, außer Unlock, äh, nee, Crypt, Crypt Root Unlock kann ich ausführen. Man fragt
da mich nach dem Passwort, ich geb das jetzt mal ein und switch schnell rüber und ihr
seht, er hat Unlocked und Booted. Das heißt, die Remote-Konsole brauchen wir ab jetzt nicht
mehr. Und schon haben wir einen Ubuntu Server, komplett selbst installiert, mit Root, also
Full Encryption, kann man dort den Anmeldenname auch ändern, äh, ich glaube nicht, ich bin
mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher, keine Ahnung. Man kann das Ganze noch viel schöner
machen, also ich hat es bei mir auf dem Server immer so, dass man sich gar nicht mehr bei
Busybox einloggen muss, sondern, dass man direkt das Unlock-Script aufgeploppt kriegt
und einfach nur ein Passwort eingeben muss. Aber, so, also wir haben komplett Encrypted
in Ubuntu Server, mit Remote-Unlogging. So, und wie man das jetzt normalerweise macht,
zeige ich euch mal, mal angenommen, ihr, ähm, achso, eine Sache sollten wir übrigens noch
machen. Eine, eine, eine Sache sollten wir, ah nee, müssen wir ja gar nicht. Müssen wir
ja gar nicht, passt. Was wird mit dem Server gemacht? Äh, Stream. Im Stream demonstrieren,
wie man sowas machen kann. Ähm, kannst du das zeigen? Nein, das kann ich aus dem Kopf
nicht zeigen. Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, wie es funktioniert. Das ist ein bisschen
komplizierter. Da muss man irgendeinen Force SSH-Command anlegen in der Config und das
ist ein bisschen komplizierter gewesen. Aber in der Busybox kann man ja eh nichts machen,
ohne Festplatte zu anloggen. So, und wie, was man jetzt macht, ist folgendes, also mal angenommen,
man hat hier irgendwie mal wieder ein Upgrade gemacht und ein kernel-Update gemacht, man
muss rebooten, dann macht man das wie gehabt. Übrigens, eine Sache, die ich auch immer,
immer gerne installiere, ist, ich weiß, das ist uralt, aber das installiere ich immer
gerne und was das macht, ist folgendes, finde ich unglaublich praktisch, wenn ihr Reboot
eingebt, dann sagt der, Moment, bist du dir sicher, dass du rebooten willst? Der reboote
da nicht einfach. Obwohl man root ist, der reboote nicht einfach. Und dann musst du
den Server-Name eingeben, in dem Fall hier Qt-Server und ähm, wenn ich es falsch eingebe,
geht es übrigens auch nicht. Wenn ich eingebe Qt-Server, dann rebooted er. So, also ich
habe jetzt Updates gemacht, kernel-Update dabei gewesen, ich reboote jetzt, Server geht
aus, rebooted, dann kann ich in der Zwischenzeit meinen Ping absetzen und gucken, wann ist
denn der Server wieder da? Ich hoffe, das Ding antwortet auf Ping. Ja, so, Server ist
wieder da, dann mache ich mein SSH und komme in mein Unlock-Ding, unlocke, werde wieder
rausgeschmissen, warte, bis der Server vollständig gebootet ist und verbinde mich drauf und da
sind wir. Custom installierte Subundoserver ISO, Full Encrypted, inklusive Systemplatte
und Remote-Unlocken. Also viel bequemer geht es nicht mehr. Ähm, Kellmor, das geht theoretisch,
das müsste theoretisch gehen, wenn du irgendeinen, irgendeinen, du könntest ja irgendeinen
Boot-Skript basteln, ja, du könntest irgendeinen Boot-Skript basteln, was sich ausführt, dann
müsstest du nur gucken, wie du Looks dazu überredet kriegst, das Zeug dann irgendwie
anzunehmen. Also ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie man das machen könnte, machbar
bestimmt, dass sich der Server noch selbst irgendwie anlockt. Eigentlich eine richtig
coole Idee, muss man sagen, dass man quasi so einen Master-Server hat und solange der
online ist und mit irgendwas speziell antwortet, entlocken sich die Server selbst, irgendwie
so, ja, könnte man bestimmt was machen. Ja, das müsste ich mir mal tiefer, tiefgreifender
Gedanken machen. So, das war jetzt die mit Abstand komplizierteste Sache, die ich jemals
machen musste, um so ein System zu bekommen. Also ich hab bei keinem anderen Provider und
bei keiner anderen Cloud-VM-Geschichte bisher so Probleme gehabt, das System hier einzurichten
wie bei Hetzner. Wenn ihr wollt, können wir mal Digital Ocean auch noch mal kurz was
machen, dass ihr seht, dass es auch viel einfacher geht. Wollen wir noch schnell mal Digital
Ocean machen? Kann man nicht Lux-FIFO-Zeugs entschlüsseln? Doch, irgendwie kann man, ja,
doch kann man. Du müsstest dann quasi das Passwort von einem anderen Server abfragen
oder irgendwelche Magic machen, dass der das bekommt und dann kannst du das Pipen nach
Unlock-FIFO-Dings, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht. Das müsste schon irgendwie gehen.
Doch, ich glaub schon, dass Hetzner das benutzt. Die machen aber halt leider komische Netzwerk-Geschichten.
Moin, Tanser. Würdest du allgemein Digital Ocean gegenüber Hetznern bevorzugen? Eigentlich
nicht. Ich mag Digital Ocean zwar, erstens weil es total einfach ist und weil die Kisten,
man kann nicht sagen besser funktionieren, aber qualitativ finde ich, sind die Digital
Ocean Kisten besser. Da sind überall SSDs drunter und die fühlen sich ein bisschen,
das geht alles ein bisschen schneller auf Digital Ocean, ja. Aber Digital Ocean kostet
eine ganze Ecke mehr, gerade bei Kisten mit viel RAM und viel CPU. Und ich muss ja einmal
im Monat das ASCII-Quarium an, weil ich weiß, dass die Aufmerksamkeit der Leute nicht so
hoch ist im Jahr 2020. Das ist dann so ein bisschen zum beruhigen. Wo bin ich jetzt stehengeblieben?
Genau, aber gerade bei Servern, die viel RAM haben und die auch viel CPUs haben, ist Hetzner
kosten nur die Hälfte von Digital Ocean. Also ich muss ja einmal im Monat Routing-Informationen
von OpenStreetView pre-processen und da brauche ich sowas hierfür. Das reicht gar nicht
dafür. Ich brauche etwas noch Fetteres. Und das geht. Ich glaube, das geht aktuell nur
nicht, weil ich noch kein Kontingent erhöht habe. Das geht erst nach der ersten Abrechnung.
Also ich brauche da 96G RAM, 96G RAM, hier Pricing, Hetzner Cloud. Na Dedicated ist doof,
Dedicated geht ja nicht stundenweise. Es gibt hier auch mehr RAM, aber nur wenn man sein
Kontingent aufgesch... Find ich blöd? Ich hab doch letztens extra mal nachgeguckt. Hä?
Die haben doch letztens... Ach hier. Das da. So ein Ding. Gibt's ja nicht. So ein Ding
bräuchte ich da zum Beispiel. Das kann man hier wahrscheinlich nicht... Da muss ich wahrscheinlich
mein Limit irgendwie erhöhen. Wie dem auch sei, so eine Kiste brauche ich einmal im Monat.
Bisher nehme ich immer die hier. Och wo ist die Musik hin? Bisher nehme ich immer die
hier. Find ich auch was mit 96G? Bisher nehme ich immer die hier und die kosten halt das
doppelte wie bei Hetzner. Hier kostet es im Monat 960 Dollar. Im Monat. Das klingt jetzt
viel, aber das ist nicht wild, weil was mich interessiert ist die stündliche Abrechnung.
Und das ist für mich auch der riesen Vorteil so Cloud-Gedöns zu verwenden. Du kannst dir
da brutal heftige Kisten mieten. Wenn du die nur kurz brauchst, ist das recht günstig.
Ich miete mir einmal im Monat für zwei Stunden sowas hier. Zum Preprocessen von Open Street
für Routing-Informationen. Das braucht RAM-as-fuck, also 90GB plus, ist super parallelisierbar
und ordentlich SSD im Zweifelfall scheint an, schadet auch nichts. Zum Einlesen der
ganzen Daten. Also ich pre-processe das ungefähr in eineinhalb Stunden, wohingegen ich bei
mir daheim ewig brauchen würde, weil ich eben nicht annähernd so viel RAM drinne hab.
Kannst du bei Punkt 3 nicht aus Detikate aussehen, weißt du, dann musst du mal ausprobieren.
Nö, wo denn? Ich glaube das kann man normalerweise schon, wenn man... Ach hier, ich bin so doof,
ich hab's nicht gesehen. Ja, aber das mein ich, mein Limit ist zu gering. Mein Limit
ist zu gering, ich muss erst einmal im Monat bezahlen. Ich muss erst einmal im Monat bezahlen
hier. Ähm, dass das funktioniert. So und das ist mir zu wenig RAM. Zumindest worauf
ich raus wollte ist, das ist halt so mein Anwendungszweck was solche Cloud-Geschichten
angeht unter anderem. Und dafür lohnt sich das. Wozu sowas kaufen ist komplett sinnlos
für wenn man das 2 Stunden im Monat braucht. Und der Download und das Ziehen der Daten
ist auch mega schnell. 8TB Transfer reicht locker. So. Ja Leute, wollen wir noch mal schnell
in Digital Ocean reingucken, dass ihr seht, dass es nicht so kompliziert sein muss wie
bei Hetzner. Was kann man eigentlich mit Cephs machen, verteilte Storage. Das ist im Stream,
das ist ne gute Idee. Da, sehr gut. Nicht J, nicht J, JS. Alter. CephJS, das gibt's
bestimmt. Moment, das muss ich jetzt suchen. CephJS. Scheiß gibt's tatsächlich. CephFS.
Also bei mir sagen die, ich kann jetzt leider nicht in meine Abrechnung rein, bei mir sagen
die, ich muss hier das Limit erhöhen. Irgendwo in meinem Account kann ich das Limit erhöhen,
aber ich kann erst das Limit erhöhen, nachdem ich Monats Abrechnung einmal bezahlt habe.
Das ist so ne Vorkehrung von denen wahrscheinlich, dass Leute nicht hergehen und im Monat die
fetteste Kiste mieten und danach nicht bezahlen.
Also Jett mit Digital Ocean nochmal mal. Okay, das treibe ich mir auch mal auf. Titan,
Toaster, treibe ich mir auch mal auf. Wir können ja nicht genug Themen für den Stream
haben, wir haben schon ein paar Sachen. Also mal das Ganze mit Digital Ocean nochmal. Was
man immer nicht vergessen darf bei dieser ganzen Cloud-Geschichte ist folgendes, wenn
wir jetzt hier fertig sind. Wenn wir jetzt hier fertig sind. Ach ja, bevor ich das jetzt
weg mache, wollt ihr noch irgendwas sehen? Auf der Ubuntu-Hetsna-Kiste. Wollen wir mal
Suspension machen? Wir machen mal Suspension-CPU. So, mal zum Vergleich. C-Matrix, oh ja, das
brauchen wir unbedingt. C-Matrix ist das Allerwichtigste. Hast du dir einen Skript gemacht, um die Routing-Daten
zu brechen oder mietest du die Kiste selbst und startest das oder machst du das? Ich
miete die Kiste, installiere Docker und nehme den offiziellen OpenStreet-StreetMaps-Routing-Docker-Container
und lasse den pre-processen. Okay, das Wichtigste, was man auf so einem Server laufen lassen
muss, verstehe ich. Übrigens, angeblich soll es ja einen vierten Teil von Matrix geben.
Kannst du bitte einen Trace-Route machen? Wir können mal gucken, wie schnell wir am
Google-DNS sind von Hetsna. Geht ziemlich zackig. Trace-Pass-Pass. Ich kann mir nicht
merken, ist es Trace-Route oder Trace-Pass? Ist es Trace-Route? Machen wir mal Hollywood.
Das mache ich jetzt auf dem Server nicht. Trace-Route. 8888. Ups. Der sollte relativ
kurz sein. Ich bin da schon vorbeigelaufen am Rack von Hetsna. Das war kein eigenes
Rack. Die hatten eine eigene Ecke. Weil ich mir jetzt im Nachhinein, wenn ich da so drüber
nachdenke, gar nicht sicher bin, ob es Hetsna war oder ob es damals sogar die Telekom war.
Es kann sein, dass ich euch jetzt Scheiße erzähle und ich doch noch nicht am Hetsna-Rack
vorbeigelaufen bin. Im Dezix. Da, wo die ihre Ehe-Route. Das könnte sein, dass das
die Telekom war mit der eigenen Ecke. Ah. Das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her. Ich
kann mich nicht mal so richtig daran erinnern. KillerCarnickel404, Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Das ist ja quasi. Excellent Subscription. Dankeschön. So, also wir sehen, wir sind
relativ schnell bei Google. Geht doch sehr zackig. Warum berechnest du Daten von Omstreetview?
Weil wir ein kleines Projekt am Laufen gerade haben für eine Web-Anwendung, wo sich Handwerker
eine praktische Route berechnen lassen können, wie sie ihre Kunden abfahren. Du sagst dann
quasi Frau Müller hat einen Termin, Frau Krabbe hat einen Termin. Hieß der Typ nicht Herbert
Krabbe oder so? Ich habe euch doch die Anwendung mal gezeigt. Der hat so einen random generierten
Namen. Du wählst die Kunden aus, die du besuchen willst und dann lässt du dir eine Route berechnen,
wie du die möglichst optimal anfahren kannst. Und dafür brauche ich Routing-Informationen.
MTR. Gibt es MTR unter Ubuntu? Und ist dieses MTR auch das MTR, was ich meine? Ne, das ist
eine GUI-Anwendung. Moment. Ne, das ist eine GUI-Anwendung. Das ist ja von Arsch. Ne, das
bringt mir überhaupt nichts. MTR GUI ist ja overrated auf dem Server. Gibt es da auch
ein CLI? Guck mal. Ne, MTR Tiny gibt es. Was ist das denn? MTR? Tiny? MTR? Aha, guck
mal da. Exzellent. Da macht mehrere Trace-Routes. Machst du gewisse Standardschritte? Ja. Ich
hab. Auch hab ich nicht. Siehst du mal. Es ist halt absolut minimal gedönnt, was der installiert
hat. Das Pre-Process muss man machen, dass man damit Routing betreiben kann. Ja, also
was ich für Standardschritte mache, nachdem ich, also wenn ich das System voran installiere,
ist eigentlich folgendes. Moment, muss erst mal fertig werden. Ja. Okay, jetzt macht ihr
irgendwelche Man-Pages aktualisieren. Das dauert mir schon viel zu lang. Also ich zeige
euch gleich, was ich standardmäßig immer mache. So, also ich installiere immer, installiere
immer das, obwohl ich gemerkt nur Bundtube habe, aber auf der Arbeit mit Red Hat ist es
was anderes. T-Max, Wim, H-Top. Irgendwas vergessen. D-Stat. Ach ja, und falls es nicht
drauf ist, Bash-Completion. Aber das ist meistens schon drauf. So, die Sachen installiere ich
meistens und die Stat ist noch nicht drauf. Die Stat ist ja auch mittlerweile outdated.
Ehm, OnKS. Die Stat ist ganz gut, um sich den IO anzeigen zu lassen. Das ist ganz angenehm.
Dom-PC. Angeschön, sieben Monate. Hypersubscriber hier. Also das finde ich an T-Stat ganz praktisch
und H-Top ist eh die bessere Alternative, um sich anzeigen zu lassen, was auf dem Server
alles los ist. LLServe ist auch praktisch, ja. F-User, ganze Affe. Also gibt ein paar Sachen.
Das sind eigentlich so die Standard-Sachen, die ich immer installiere. T-Max, hat jemand
gefragt, was das ist? T-Max ist quasi so ein Fenstermanager fürs Terminal. Also das ist
das, was du hier unten bei mir auch gerade siehst. Ich kann es auch auf dem Server anmachen.
Na, da kannst du so Sachen machen, wie unterschiedliche Tabs auf, dein Terminal splitten, ähm,
du kannst hier unten beispielsweise einen H-Top laufen lassen und hier oben, hier oben
ein Susbench. Ah, da kannst du nämlich unten gucken, was das für Auslastungen verursacht
und oben siehst du was und dann kannst du verschiedene Tabs auch wechseln, vor und
zurück. Das ist quasi ein Fenstermanager fürs Terminal. Und das ist, äh, nützlich.
Das ist quasi I3 für Arme, wenn man kein I3 hat, ja. Richtig. Jetzt ist der Server
voll ausgelastet. Wir können übrigens mal gucken, was da drin ist. Äh, ein CPU-Kern.
Ähm, dann machen wir, äh, Proc, CPU-Info. Gucken wir rein, was ist denn da unten drunter
bei Hetzner? Da kann man das Fenster hier groß machen beispielsweise, da sieht man dann
wieder alles. Ähm, da ist drinnen InterXeon. Welchen erkennt man nicht genau, das haben
die wahrscheinlich in KVM, äh, überschrieben oder ausgeschaltet, aber einer, der Meltdown
Spectre und Spectre Frau 2 anfällig ist. Exzellent, aber das Ubuntu, äh, vor allem
in der VM ist das jetzt nicht so wild. Wobei eigentlich ist es überall wild, aber ich
gehe mal davon aus, dass es gepatcht. Ähm, einer, der AVX hat, einer, der wahrscheinlich,
der wahrscheinlich Hardware Encryption hat. Das sehe ich jetzt hier allerdings nicht.
Der AES hat ja, also eine relativ moderne CPU. Jo. Scheint halbwegs moderne CPU zu sein.
Äh, in der VM ist schlecht. Wenn, wenn das unten drunter nicht gepatcht ist bei denen,
würde es sucken, ja. Da gibt's, da kannst du dir eh nicht sicher sein. So. Gibt's
sonst irgendwas, was man, was ihr wissen wollt auf der Ubuntu Kiste? Installierst du auf
dem Server auch immer TMAX? Wenn ja, bringt es dir auf deinem TMAX in einer Session bis
nächste Session. Lass dich ja nicht gezielt. Äh, doch, doch installiere ich immer. Also.
Äh, doch, lassen sie. Du musst einfach den Escape zweimal drücken. Guck. Das ist ja,
ich kann ja nächste Session hier gerade steuern. Äh, wobei ich mir jetzt gerade angewöhnt
hab, für, oder angewöhnt will, für mein lokales TMAX-Steuerung A zu verwenden, dass
ich auf dem Server-Steuerung B für das TMAX verwenden kann. Woran erkennst du, ob die
CPU Hardware-Encryption kann? Ich guck nach den Flags und wenn da AES drinne steht, interpretier
ich da jetzt einfach mal rein, dass die Hardware-Encryption kann. Aber hundertprozentig sicher bin ich
mir nicht, ob das Flag das bedeutet. Da müssen wir erstmal nachgucken. Äh, weiß ich jetzt
aus dem Kopf nicht. Ich würde aber vermuten, das ist es. So. Dann machen wir das Ganze
jetzt nochmal in Digital-Ocean und ihr werdet sehen, das dauert fünf Minuten und dann geht
alles. Viel angenehmer als bei Hetzner. Können das nicht oft auch die Festplatten direkt?
Es geht nicht um Encryption. Ach doch, eine Sache machen wir noch. Crypt Setup Benchmark.
Wir müssen mal gucken, wie schnell das Ding fair und entschlüsselt. Gut, dass wir drüber
sprechen. Da sehen wir nämlich auch, ob das AES Encryption hat. Ähm, es geht ja nicht
um IO, es geht ja nicht um Festplattenverschlüsselung. Wenn deine CPU Encryption Crypto-Extension
hast, dann kannst du beispielsweise auch einen SSL Load Balancer machen, der halt viel schneller
ist, als ohne. Also man braucht das nicht nur für die Festplatte, man braucht das für
alles mögliche, wo Encrypted wird und Decrypted wird. Wird wahrscheinlich Hardware Accelerated
sein, ja. So, wunderbar. Sonst noch Fragen zu Ubuntu? Ich gucke mal kurz in mein Board,
weil ich habe bestimmt jede Menge Fragen übersehen. Und dann werde ich euch zeigen, wie easy es
mit Digital Ocean ist, das Ganze zu machen. Also, gab es überhaupt Fälle, wo Spectre
Meld darin ausgewiesen ist, weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht. Ja. Wie gesagt, mache ich immer.
Ich habe auf meinem kleinen Teamaxe laufen, auf dem Server Teamaxe laufen. Du musst einfach
doppelt Escape drücken dafür, dass man es steuern kann. Ähm, also Steuerung B, Steuerung
B, dann geht es an den Server. Oder du legst den Shortcut von deinem lokalen Teamaxe um.
Was ist das für Musik, irgendeine Chillstep Playlist auf YouTube? Ja, das war. Habe ich
mich getäuscht oder hat die Ubuntu die Open-VM-Tools installiert? Kann durchaus sein, ja. Das ist
wahrscheinlich die Fault. Warum Maps? Ah, das ist eine gute Frage. Warum Maps berechnen?
Reicht das nicht Google Maps? Google Maps ist teuer, wenn man über das Freikontingent
kommt. Und was wir als Routing brauchen, können wir mit Google Maps nicht so einfach machen.
Wir brauchen, ähm, quasi mehrere Fahrzeuge mit Zeitfenstern, wann die Leute kommen. Und
das kann Google Maps standardmäßig nicht. Das ist quasi mehrfach Traveling Seltsam ein
Problem mit Time-Window. Also das kann Google Maps so out of the box nicht. Das geht bestimmt
um fünf Ecken. Ganz bestimmt. Aber wir verwenden dafür eine andere Software, die das macht
und die benutzt als Routing-Information OpenStreetMap und die kann das schon eingebaut. Weil selbst
programmieren bin ich dazu Low-Brain-Führer. Hab ich schon. Was war nochmal Quite und Splash?
Na, dass er Ausgabe macht beim Booten und dass er keinen Boot-Logo anzeigt. Das hatten
wir vorher schon. Tops haben wir vorher auch schon. Warum sind da so viele CAC-Ws auf einmal
im Chat? Ja, wie gesagt, KVM gehe ich ganz stark von aus. Hab ich schon gemacht. Haben
wir jetzt ja auch gemacht. Das ist aber unglücklich, dass das rein vom Stromleiste rausziehen passiert.
Deswegen haben ordentlich die Rate-Controller-Buffer-Batterien drinne. Aber schon ASM 6 Nachspurt? Nein,
hab ich noch nicht gemacht. Einzige Assembler, was ich in letzter Zeit mal angefasst habe,
war der vom ESP32-Ultra-Low-Power-CPU-Ding. Und diesem 8MHz-Ding. Wie hast du die Elektrotechnik
beigebracht? Gar nicht. Ich sacke übelst in Elektrotechnik. Und im Zweifelsfall, wenn
ich selbst irgendwelche Sachen baue, dann ist erstmal MonkaSmoke angesagt. So. Und Mist,
falls du noch da bist, erklär mir doch jetzt mal, wie du das mit Terraform machen willst,
was ich heute gemacht habe. Wird über die Konsole und dem ISO gemountet und sonst was.
Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es nicht irgendwie hackstormmäßig geht, aber das will
keiner maintainen. Lohnt es sich KVM-Verschlüsselung? Ähm, das ist ein bisschen zu allgemein gefragt,
was genau hatten wir schon gar nicht. Doch, an Silvester wahrscheinlich wieder. Ich drehe
das ein bisschen. Ok, dann installieren. Ach, das ist noch vom letzten Stream, ne? Will
man bis auf Gaming gerne komplett auf Linus umsteigen. Ja, dann viel Spaß. Da musst du
immer Dual Booten. Die meisten Sachen, gerade Multiplayer-Geschichten mit Anti-Cheat kannst
du knicken. So, jetzt machen wir das Ganze nochmal im Schnelldurchgang auf Terraform.
Äh, was laber ich von Scheiß? Lowbrain. Wir machen das jetzt im Schnelldurchgang auf
Digital Ocean. Dann seht ihr mal einen ganz anderen Weg, wie man das machen kann. Und
wir machen auch nicht alles. Also das Entschlüsseln und so machen wir nicht, nur das Installieren.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie das geht. Viel einfacher mit Digital Ocean. Viel, viel einfacher.
Und, ähm, ganz anderer Weg, wie wir es bei Hetzner gemacht haben. Also ich erstelle mal
einen Digital... Achso, übrigens, by the way, wenn wir fertig sind mit Hetzner, keiner
mehr eine Frage hat zu der Hetzner-Geschichte, dann lösche ich das Ding jetzt. Weil, das
darf man bei der ganzen Cloud-Thematik nie vergessen. Sonst wird's nämlich teuer. Letzte
Chance, irgendwas auf dem Hetzner selber zu gucken. Leute, ich geh mal kurz was zu trinken
holen. Und dann löschen wir die Hetzner-Kiste.
Okay, dann löschen wir die Hetzner-Kiste.
So, also, weder da hab ich irgendwas übersehen im Chat. Nee, sieht nicht so aus. Gut. Also,
dann schmeißen wir das Ding weg. Zack, bumm. Fertig, sauber weg. Und ihr seht, RIP. Dann
machen wir jetzt mal was auf Digital Ocean. Wir werden sehen, viel einfacher, viel angenehmer.
Gleiche Voraussetzung wie bei Hetzner. 2004, Basic, in Frankfurt, mein erster Saki, blablub,
das war das Create. So, das ist noch kein Unterschied. Das ist eigentlich mehr oder
weniger genau das gleiche. Nur in Blau. Und Achtung Leute, aufpassen, gleich wieder
IP Leak. Leak, schau wieder. Heute wird ja nur noch geleakt. Ups, hat er das nicht copy-pasted.
So, gehen wir auf die Kiste drauf. Und jetzt fahren wir auf einen ganz anderen Weg. Ähm,
wir sehen, wir sind auf einer Ubuntu-Kiste drauf bei Digital Ocean. Übrigens, das ist
auch eine Sache. Ähm, ich sag ja immer, man muss sich überlegen. Also, Cloud-Hype hin
oder her. Man muss sich immer legen, was passt für die jeweilige Anwendung und Architektur,
die man haben möchte. Aber für sowas ist die ganze Cloud-Geschichte echt cool. Einfach
mal auf Knopfdruck eine Kiste erzeugen, Minuten oder Stundenweise bezahlen und wieder wegschmeißen.
Wunderbar. Du hast ein Pepega-Board in Elektronen geschrieben. Na dann. Ja, Moment. Kann das
auch Overlays? Also Windows, Windows-Overlays und bedienbar über den anderen Rechner.
So, jetzt haben wir die Digital-Ocean-Geschichte. Und jetzt machen wir es uns viel, viel einfacher.
Nämlich jetzt gehen wir auf netboot.xyz. Ähm, nehmen wir uns hier den Guide für Digital
Ocean und sagen, ok, was brauchen wir hier? Diesen ganzen Guide brauchen wir nicht. Das
hier ist das Interessante. Das brauchen wir. Wim-etc-crop, das ist genau das gleiche, was
ich beim anderen auch gemacht habe. Nur, dass ich jetzt netboot verwenden kann. Hups. Set
paste. Und dann sehen wir, wie easy as fuck das ist, wenn die einem nicht so einen Strich
durch die Rechnung machen, wie bei Hetzner. So, dann gehen wir nach slashboot, laden uns
ähm netbot. Nein, nicht netbot, netboot. Laden uns das jeweilige passende Image runter
für netboot. Und ihr werdet lachen, das war's schon. Richtige Festplatte auswählen. Das
war's schon. Mehr muss man nicht machen bei Digital Ocean. Update Crop. Achso, eine Sache
sollte man auch machen. Man sollte in der default, default scrub, sollte man einstellen,
dass der ähm, den dritten Eintrag lädt, damit er auch das Richtige bootet. Äh, was machst
du? Also was wir heute schon gemacht haben ist, wir haben uns bei Hetzner eine VM gemietet
oder eine Cloud-Kiste, unter der Haube ist es eine KVM-VM, ähm, haben dort custom Ubuntu
installiert mit, äh, komplett Vollverschlüsselung inklusive Unlock über SSH. Und wir haben keine
Sachen von Hetzner dafür benutzt. Wir haben alles, äh, quasi custom ISO, custom install
gemacht. Ohne Rescue Mode von Hetzner, ohne ISO von Hetzner. War ein bisschen trickreich,
ja. So, und jetzt wollen wir das Ganze mit Digital Ocean und wollte ich mal zeigen, dass
es viel einfacher sein kann. So, wenn wir jetzt rebooten, moin, Luke Kuh, Leo Kuh, ich
weiß, du bist öfters da und ich kann es nie aussprechen. So, wenn wir hier jetzt ein
Reboot machen, äh, wir gehen erstmal in die Konsole, in die Konsole von, von dem TROPLET,
da heißen sie TROPLET, das ist im Prinzip eine VM. So, und wenn ich jetzt reboote, werden
wir sehen, zack, wir landen im CRUB. Oder auch nicht. Warum sind wir nicht im CRUB gelandet,
oder? Was hab ich falsch gemacht? Moment, warum sind wir nicht im CRUB gelandet? Äh,
ahnung, Menu, Timeout 5, Quiet Splash, mach mal weg. Warum sind wir nicht im CRUB gelandet?
Wir müssten, wir müssten eigentlich im CRUB landen. Ja, Update CRUB hab ich gemacht.
Mal Escape hemmern. Ah, da sind wir, guck, hier. Habt ihr gesehen, hat funktioniert.
Dann macht das Netboot. Ähm, Digital Ocean verwendet kein DHCP, das heißt, ich muss
jetzt selbst konfigurieren, was auch kein Problem ist. Ich sag einfach Netzwerk 0, IP kann
ich hier unten abtippen, 64, 109, 101, 109, 55, Subnetmar, 255, 255, 255, 192.0, Gatefave,
was? Oh. Äh, ich glaub, ich hab mich grad irgendwie verteppt, kann das sein? Äh, ja,
ich hab mich... Rich Pepega Style, Alter. Äh, wie startet man das jetzt neu? Äh, kann
ich, kann ich hier irgendwie Ctrl Alt? Ne, warte mal, wie startet man neu? Das muss ich
so selten machen, hier, off. Turn off, bam. Wir lassen, wir lassen es einfach mal ausschalten,
umgutes. Das ist ein Nachteil bei Digital Ocean, die brauchen teilweise mega lang, bis
eine VM ausgeschaltet ist. Ich hab mich ein bisschen verteppt, aber ihr habt gesehen,
dass es prinzipiell bis jetzt deutlich einfacher als bei Hetzner war. Neuen Standard empfunden,
Alter. Alter, Surfer, geh aus. IPv5 erfunden, nebenbei. Sag mal, hallo? Ausgehen? Ja, ich
ausgehen. Moment, der braucht genaue Beobachtung. Dann geht er aus. Pass auf, pass auf, gleich
geht er aus. Dann muss ich ihn einfach nur post-champen. Einfach nur post-champen, dann
geht's schneller. Hast du mal ein Freeway ESP probiert? Nur in Form von Open Sense und
PF-Sense. Noch nie als Hauptbetriebssystem-Aufpensäuber. Ja, jetzt guck, guck, man muss ihn post-champen
und schon geht er aus. Kennst du das IPv4++? Nein, das kenn ich nicht. Okay, jetzt nicht
vertippen, nicht vertippen. Max, nicht vertippen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du was verpasst hast, ich
weiß nicht, wann du weg bist. Max, nicht vertippen. Kannst du gerade mal erzählen, was dein gesamter
Plan ist? Also wir haben das ja eigentlich schon gemacht bei Hetzner und zwar Custom
ISO, manuelle Setup, Ubuntu Server, komplette Festplatten, Vollverschlüsselung mit eigenem
Passwort, inklusive Entsperren über SSH. Okay, also jetzt nicht vertippen. 4, 6, 1,
0, 1, 1, 0, 9, 5, 5, 2, 5, 2, 5, 2, 5, 2, 9, 9, Max ruhig langsam, langsam, 1, 9, 2,
Punkt 0. Gateway 4, 6, 1, 0, 1, 1, 0, 2, 1, DNS 8, 8, 8, fertig. Und zack, guck, geht
so einfach. Hätte es bei Hetzner auch sein können. Und jetzt kann ich einfach sagen,
okay, Linux Network installs, Ubuntu und schon läuft das Scheiß. Liest ihr mal, oh nee,
das wird zu viel installen. Wenn ich geflame sehen will, guck ich mir die alten Posts von
Linus Torwart auf der Linus-Mailing-Neste an, dann ist genug geflame. So, guck, zack,
so einfach kann es gehen. Habt ihr gesehen, wie easy das sein kann, wenn, und das alles
nur, weil Hetzner komische Netzwerkgeschichten macht. Die neuen sind etwas weniger vulgär.
Er flamet immer noch gerne rum, aber die sind nicht mal ganz so heftig. So, mal gucken,
wie gut das jetzt hier durchläuft. Schauen wir mal. Oh, oh nee, Kurago, wo ist denn Kurago?
Nein, nicht Zentralamerika, meine Güte, ich kann da tippen. Ich bin Europe. So, Europe.
Germany. Weiter. Yes. Y ist ein Öki da. Was, was? Oh. Yes. Ich glaub, die Autotastaturerkennung
spackt ein bisschen rum über die Konsole. Ich weiß auch, dass es Kurasau heißt und
nicht Kurakau. Linus mag keine Nvidia, ja. Auch zurecht, was er da erzählt hat. Ich muss
kurz den Timeout abwarten. Ich wählt Keyboard von Hand aus. No. Ganz einfach. German. German
und dann no dead keys. So, und ihr seht überhaupt kein Problem mit der Installation. Einzige,
was nicht funktioniert, ist DRCP, weil was hat Linus denn so zu Nvidia erzählt? Der hat
gesagt, fuck you Nvidia, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab. Aber die Finden sind oft so.
Also ich hab das jetzt schon öfters gelesen, dass wenn Finden Englisch reden, dass Finden
wohl an sich relativ viel fluchen und wenn Finden Englisch reden, fluchen sie halt auch
in Englisch. Ich weiß nur, dass die Finden immer Teufel sagen, oder? Die sagen immer
Perkille. Heißt es nicht Teufel? Oder zum Teufel? Irgendwie sowas auf Finish. So, jetzt
müssen wir den ganzen Spawner nochmal von Hand eintragen. Lp-Adresse 46.101.109.55.
Zmask nein, ausnahmsweise nicht. 192.0. Gateway 192.1. Nameserver Google. Ihr seht, wie einfach
es funktionieren kann, ne? View to Chat. Keine Domain. Germany Mirror. Ubuntu Archive Deutschland.
Kein Proxy. Wie easy das sein kann, ne? Bei Hetzen haben wir noch ne Stunde für rumgemacht.
Hier machst du einfach Netboot bei Digital Ocean und es funktioniert. Also ich denke,
ich muss das jetzt nicht nochmal alles neu demonstrieren, sondern man sieht, dass es
deutlich einfacher funktioniert in dem Fall. Ja, Proxmox geht genauso. Es geht jedes x-beliebige
ISO, was Netboot kann. Total easy. Und theoretisch kann man Netboot auch auf ne Custom-Ul machen
und dann irgendein eigenes File laden lassen. Ja, das ist alles hier über Digital Ocean.
Es ist total einfach im Vergleich zu dem rumgefuddelt, was wir da bei Hetzen machen mussten. Und
es lag einzig und allein daran gar nicht, dass es so ein großer Unterschied ist, sondern
das Hetzen hat so ne merkwürdige DHCP-Config verwendet. Oder was? Ja, die IP-Vergabe ist
ein. Endlich Henna Montana Linux in Digital Ocean. Wir können mal gucken, was bietet Netboot
denn an. Warte, ich starte mal während das installiert. Wir gucken mal schnell, was die
anbieten. Ich hab mir doch hier so ne Netboot-Geschichte gemacht. Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal, was
Netboot alles anbietet. Hetzena ist halt schön günstig. Hetzena bezahlt ein Drittel bis
die Hälfte zu Digital Ocean für fette Kisten. Du kannst dich nicht beschweren, ansonsten
es funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. So, Linux Network installs. Was haben wir da zu bieten?
Was kann die denn? LPN, Anarchy, Arch Linux, BlackArch, CentOS, Container Linux, das ist
immer Debian, Devo. Das ist dieses ganz besonders freie Debian, glaube ich. Fedora, Gentoo,
WP-Fire, irgendwelche Kubernetes-Geschichten, Kali Linux hätten wir auch am Start. Krassen
Hexor unter uns. OpenSuse, TinyCalling, das ist im Prinzip alles Mögliche dabei. Scientific
ist ja quasi ein Red Hat. Ich hatte auch bis jetzt noch nie Probleme bei Hetzena. Ich
hab da aber nicht viel laufen gehabt. So, man kann BSDs. Was haben wir für Live-CDs
zu bieten? Devos World, Debian, Fedora. Also man muss sagen, die haben bei Netboot fast
alles dabei, was es irgendwie so gibt. Da kann man sich nicht beschweren. Wo man keine
Custom-Ul auswählen. Die Konsole hat sich disconnected. Was habe ich denn da für eine
Kiste genommen? Ich habe eine viel zu fette Kiste genommen dafür. 8G Memory 160. Ich habe
nicht die kleinste ausgewählt. Ich bezahle jetzt viel zu viel, also 5 Cent mehr oder so.
Aber ich habe ja heute ein paar Subs gekriegt. Da ist das Ganze erträglich. Da werde ich
die 5 Cent verkraften. Ja, aber Leute, so großartig weiter muss ich das jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
zeigen. Man sieht, wie easy es on DigitalOcean ist und dank der Netzwerk-Config ist es halt
auf Hetzen ein bisschen komplizierter. Gibt es noch irgendwas, das ich ausprobieren soll?
Also theoretisch habe ich noch eine Stunde Zeit. Oder wollt ihr irgendwas wissen? Gibt
es irgendwas wichtiges noch? Also Technik-Geschichten, Linux-Fragen, Netzwerketöne. Ihr könnt mich
alles fragen, was ihr wollt. Wir haben jetzt noch eine Stunde Zeit. Morgen Geil, Mittagessen.
FeelsBatman. Aber das wäre gar nicht so schlimm, weil das hier. Cobalt-Stream, na jetzt nicht.
Jetzt machen wir einen Cobalt-Stream. Cobalt-Stream machen wir an Weihnachten irgendwann. Bist du
eigentlich immer noch komplett im Home-House? Ja. Cisco Meraki hört sich an wie ein Crossover
aus einer Automarke und Cisco. Nee, habe ich noch nichts gehört. Per Mac-Adresse, weiß
ich jetzt nicht, was das genau in dem Kontext bedeuten soll. Schonmal mit Zev gearbeitet,
aber ganz am Rande. Wir haben eine Zev-Installation bei uns auf der Arbeit. Ja, das war's. Habe
ich aber nicht viel mitgemacht. Schreibt man ein Betriebssystem mit HTML? Du könntest
heute wahrscheinlich weite Bereiche tatsächlich in JavaScript und im Browser basteln. Ich
meine, für die ganz Low-Level-Boot-Geschichten brauchst du noch was anderes, aber man könnte
heute bestimmt ziemlich weit. Guck dir Chrome OS an, da ist auch einfach viel Web-Geschiss
dabei. Nutzt du eigentlich so moderne Linux-Command-Line-Tools, die leben wie BAT oder FD? Teilweise, aber nicht
so viel wie andere, weil ich erstens schon an vieles gewöhnt bin und zweitens es dann
doof ist, wenn man sich zu sehr daran gewöhnt ist, dass auf irgendwelche Surfer nicht drauf
ist. Was ich verwende ist das da. Exa als LS-Ersatz. Das ist einfach hübscher und zeigt
auch mehr an und finde ich auch übersichtlicher. Also das ist bei mir ein Alias auf Exa. LS,
das verwende ich. FZF verwende ich, habe ich jetzt hier nicht drauf, verwende ich auch
manchmal. FZF, wer das nicht kennt, das ist sehr praktisch. Ein Fuzzy-Finder, also sprich,
damit kann man, ich zeige es euch gleich einmal, damit kann man, wenn man jetzt Dateien sucht,
wenn man jetzt Dateien sucht, kann ich beispielsweise sagen, ok, Monka 5.1 und dann sucht er mir
die Dateien quasi, während ich tippe. Also FZF ist sehr praktisch. Das benutze ich. Eigentlich
Exa und FZF, das sind die zwei einzigen, die ich glaube ich, so neu, New Style Commandline
Tools. Weil wir können den Next-Lot-Ordner mal löschen, vom letzten Mal. Und den Docker-Ordner
können wir auch vom letzten Mal löschen. Ach ja, und ich habe RM durch Trash ersetzt,
dass es erstmal in Papierkorb kommt. Ansonsten, ansonsten eigentlich ziemlich old school. Ich
bin immer noch hin und her gerichtet zwischen IF-Config und IP-Add. IP-Add ist eindeutig
das Neue, ja. Aber ich bin einfach so gewöhnt an IF-Config. Genauso wie ich auch immer
noch root-n mache, anstatt IP-Row und solche Sachen. No, du hast gar nicht, nee. Nutzt
eigentlich Digital-Ocean-KVM? Ja, gehe ich ganz stark davon aus, dass es auch ein KVM
darunter ist. Eigentlich alle, die viel Linux virtualisieren, benutzen KVM. Kennst du einen
guten Hoster für ASP-Internet-Anwendungen? Ähm, ehrlich gesagt nicht. Aber was spricht
denn dagegen, sich bei, wo wir gerade heute uns Hetzner angeguckt haben, sich bei Hetzner
Cloud die billigste Kiste zu mieten? Klar, du kannst es bei Azure hosten, relativ easy,
aber das ist teuer. Also generell, äh, ich vergesse immer, wie diese Google Cloud-Plattform
heißt. Also Azure und AWS und, und, äh, G, äh, Gez, äh, ich hab keine, ich vergesse
mit dem Namen von der Google Cloud. GCP, genau. Das ist alles recht teuer. Du hast da allerdings
den Vorteil, dass, ähm, dass es bei vielen Sachen Free-Kontingents gibt, wo es dich nix
kostet. Vielleicht bringt dir das dann, bringt dir das dann was. Was immer geht, was immer
geht zum Hosten, ist das hier. Das ist so der, der, der Oldschool-Klassiker. Wenn da einfach
nur irgendwelche, ich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die ASP.NET Core machen. Okay, anscheinend
nicht. Das ist so der Klassiker, die gibt, die gibt es schon jahrelang. Da ist, das ist
auch ziemlich easy. Ähm, aber es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, sich eine billige Hetzner
vor einem zu kaufen und es darauf zu hosten. Oder, warum suchst du denn einen Hoster und
möchtest das nicht auf, äh, einer Cloud-Kiste hosten? Eine Hoster für Core-Anwendung ist
im Prinzip das Gleiche. Also wir haben so gemacht, die, die Geschichte, wo ich jetzt
hier schon ein paar Mal erwähnt hab, diese, äh, Routenberechnung, also die, diese Routen-Optimierungssoftware
für Handwerker, die wir da jetzt zusammengestrickt haben in der Beta. Das ist auch eine ASP.NET
Core-Anwendung und die läuft auch bei Hetzner auf einer Kiste. Und, ähm, aktuell haben
wir es, das Setup so, so easy wie möglich gemacht. Eine Instanz pro Kunde, gibt ja auch
nur ein Beta-Kunde aktuell. Ähm, äh, eine Instanz pro Kunde und da vorne ein Cutty-Reverse-Proxy,
der SSL macht. Fertig. Das ist so die aller billigste Variante. Oh, und das nächste ist,
dass wir die Anwendung wahrscheinlich noch in den Container packen, weil, ähm, ich auch
GitHub Actions und Gedöns, äh, automatische Builds machen will. Also Hetzner ist das günstigste,
also eines der günstigsten, was du findest. Die hier, wenn du dir das anguckst, das kostet,
das kostet auch nur einen Bruchteil von Digital Ocean, also wenn du dich in den Server anlegst,
nimmst du, nimmst keine Ahnung, nimm mal ein aktuelles Ubuntu 20.04 und du nimmst
das kleinste. Ich vermute mal, ihr wollt ja einfach nur was hosten, um mal so bisschen,
so Proof of Concept oder bisschen Demo oder so. Ihr wollt wahrscheinlich nix hosten mit
richtig Dampf dahinter. Dann müsst man sich vielleicht was anderes überlegen. Aber da
kannst du hier nicht viel falsch machen mit der kleinsten Kiste. Eine CPU, 2G RAM, 20G SSD,
relativ viel Traffic und, äh, 2,89 im Monat oder 0,5 Cent die Stunde. Und auch die anderen Preise
sind relativ fair. Wenn's fetter sein soll, kann man sich überlegen, ob er bei denen nicht
vielleicht richtig Hardware sich holt oder dann vielleicht doch woanders upgradet. Ja,
das muss man dann mal gucken. Aber wenn ihr nur was kleines haben wollt, ist Hetzner top.
Also unsere Geschichte läuft aktuell, glaub ich, auf ungefähr zwei CPUs. Ich glaube,
unsere Geschichte läuft aktuell auf irgendwie sowas hier in der Richtung,
ungefähr in dieser Größenordnung für fünf Euro im Monat. Man bezahlt bei AWS,
Google und so erst mal den Namen, ziemlich, gerade bei Azure, ziemlich fett mit. Und die
haben halt auch einen ziemlich guten, einen ziemlich guten Ruf, das wissen die. Und Managementleute
sind halt lieber bereit zu sagen, wir gehen zu Azure als wir gehen zu Hetzner Cloud. Dazu kommt,
dass Azure ja neben wir hosten VMs extrem viel andere Services bietet. Von hosted Datenbanken
bis Function as a Service bis Managed Kubernetes und alles Mögliche. Also Azure hat Gott und die
Welt zum Hosten. Und das in Kombination hast du jetzt hier natürlich nicht. Hier kriegst du
VMs, musst du den Kram selber machen. Und das kann sich dann schon lohnen. Aber du bezahlst
erst mal richtig viel den Namen. Du bezahlst natürlich auch gute Standorte, Service Techniker
und alle möglichen Sachen. Das ist schon gut das Zeug und das tut halt auch und ist ab in der
Regel. Dass Azure mal irgendwo was down ist, kommt vor, aber ist doch relativ selten. Aber
wenn es was kleines sein soll, behaupte ich mal, fährst du mit so einem Hetzner Server wahrscheinlich
besser. Genau Machine Learning Zeug. Also Azure hat sehr viel mehr als einfach nur VMs. Ich
hatte ja die Ehre, letztens eine einwöchige Azure DevOps Schulung machen zu dürfen. Oh,
der Installer ist kaputt. Ah, jetzt ist er fast fertig. So habe ich irgendwas übersehen.
Wie habt ihr das mit der Datenschutzerklärung gemacht? Die haben irgendwas unterschrieben,
frag mich nicht, das habe ich nicht gemacht. Der hat mit denen irgendwas ausgemacht, was
sie dann unterschrieben haben. Keine Ahnung. Aber aktuell ist das auch noch kein Problem,
weil wir verwenden keine Live-Kundendaten. Also ich verwende halb Random-Kundendaten.
Das einzige, was bei unseren Test-Kundendaten echt ist, sind, dass es echt existierende
Adressen sind. Das ist aber auch alles. Ist das nicht öffentlich? Nein. Da kann aktuell
gerade ein Beta-Kunde drauf und später kann da auch nur derjenige drauf, für den es eingerichtet
ist. Jeder kriegt eine eigene Domain und nur dort hat er Zugangsdaten. Deswegen sage ich
ja, wir machen pro Kunde eine eigene Instanz, dann gibt es gar nicht das Problem, dass irgendjemand
was sehen könnte von dem anderen. Ja, das stimmt, da kann man theoretisch Geld sparen,
wobei ich finde, es hält sich in Grenzen. Ich muss immerhin den ganzen Server selbst
kaufen und so eine Co-Location ist jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig billig. Aber du musst
dich um wirklich jeden Scheiß selber kümmern, selbst wenn da mal was kaputt geht. Für 50
Euro im Monat kriegst du ja auch schon was ordentliches. Bestimmt nicht so was fettes,
ja, aber dafür musst du dich um nichts kümmern. Das ist halt eine Geschmacksfrage. Hast du
die letzte Headset Notebalancer schon? Nein, die habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Könntest
du mal eine Ansible Einführung machen und etwas in die Richtung empfehlen? Können wir
uns tatsächlich mal angucken, weil ich bin selbst nicht der allergrößte Ansible Pro.
Ich kann ein bisschen Playbooks lesen und auch schreiben, aber ich bin nicht der allergrößte
Ansible Pro. Das können wir uns wirklich mal zusammen angucken. Die Headset Notebalancer
habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt, wie gesagt. Ich verwende das auch nicht großartig normalerweise.
Oh, das ist Beta und die kosten auch nicht mal was. Das ist ein schönes. Sticky Sessions
bedeutet, bevor wir uns die Erklärung von der Headset angucken ist, damit ist gemeint,
dass ein Client immer auf dem gleichen Backendserver rauskommt. Also wenn ihr jetzt beispielsweise
fünf Server habt mit eurer Anwendung drauf und ein Notebalancer davor und es connectet
sich ein Client das erste Mal, dann stellt der Notebalancer sicher, dass der Client jedes
Mal danach auf dem gleichen Server rauskommt. Was wichtig sein kann, wenn es irgendwelche
Sessions, Dates oder sonst was gibt. Das versuchen sie hiermit zu beschreiben. Nee,
habe ich noch nicht angeguckt. Ja, guck mal, die Digital Ocean VM ist auch fertig zu sehen.
Also ihr habt gesehen, es ist deutlich einfacher als bei Headset Note, dank dem Letzmerkzeug,
aber unterm Strich nimmt sich das alles nichts. Ist zum Beispiel der Shop-Anwendung oder so
gut, dass der Kunde nicht ausgelockt wird. Ja, kommt ein bisschen auf die Anwendung an,
aber ja, zum Beispiel, genau. Für Sessions ist das zum Beispiel sehr praktisch. Ansonsten
müsste es irgendwie so einen Shared-State haben in der Datenbank oder sonst wo. Oder
die Server müssten sich untereinander Session-Informationen sinken. Das gibt es ja auch. Gibt es ja auch
so Varianten, dass man untereinander Session-Infos abgleicht. Aber im Prinzip ist es dafür sinnvoll
ohne größeren Aufwand seine Anwendung ein bisschen besser skalieren zu können und trotzdem,
dass sie funktioniert.
Ja, so, es startet. Es möchte ein Passwort haben. Jetzt sind wir wieder bei der gleichen
Geschichte, wie wir bei Hetzner auch schon waren. Aber es ist im Prinzip ab jetzt genau
das gleiche. Also genau das gleiche, wie wir vorher gemacht haben, mit Remote-Unlocken
und sowas. Das muss ich jetzt nicht nochmal machen, aber nach gesinnten Installationen
ist halt deutlich einfacher. So, erstmal den ganzen Kram wieder löschen, weil sonst muss
ich Geld bezahlen. So, keine Droplets mehr da. Ne, das Bild ist nicht hängen geblieben.
Das Bild läuft noch. Lautpolensi HA-Proxy. Ja, HA-Proxy ist nicht schlecht. HA-Proxy haben
wir auch. Es gibt eine schöne Sache, habe ich letztens gefunden. HA-Proxy Web-Interface.
Habe ich letztens hier, das da. Letztens gefunden auf GitHub. Macht echt einen ganz guten Eindruck,
wenn man keinen Bock hat auf Konfig-Dateien und VRP-Schwenken und so. Kann man hiermit
wohl Sachen machen. Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Letztens erst gefunden. Kann wohl nicht nur
HA-Proxy, kann auch Keep Alive und Nginx. Keine Ahnung, ob es was taugt. Das habe ich.
Du kannst ja mal probieren und berichten, ob es was taugt. Was macht denn meine Heizung
gerade? Die sollte eigentlich aus sein, weil es ist 28 Grad. Meine Heizung ist aus. Okay,
passt alles. Da bin ich ja zufrieden. Nils, it, drei Monate. Excellent Subscription,
Dankeschön. Huge Sub. Gut Leute, ich würde sagen, wir haben das geschafft, was geplant
war. Kisten sind installiert, Kisten können Remod unlocked werden. Ich hoffe, euch hat
es was gebracht, weil immerhin heute war ja Educational Content wieder angesagt. Wollt
mir eine Webcam vor der Tür platzieren, das dann auf einem Tablet streben, hab noch ein
altes iPad. Hast du eine bessere Idee? Nö, das ist doch gut. Ich habe selbst im Flur
zwei Amazon Fire HD 10s hängen als Dashboard für Heimautomatisierung und Video. Video
von den Security, also von den Kameras. Mach ich selber so. Cool, das war wirklich interessant.
War sehr lehrreich. Oh, excellent Chat. Ah, yes. Zeige euch nochmal meinen Desktop, weil
ich weiß, die Leute mögen meinen Desktop so. Monka Toss Bild am Desktop, das glaube ich
nicht, aber nicht. Also einzige, was hier auf dem Desktop ist, dass wirklich Monka,
dass wahrscheinlich das Monka Toss selber hier irgendwo drauf ist. Ansonsten habe ich
hier keine Monka Toss Bilder. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Anzeige ist raus. Ich habe noch Blast
RNG auf dem Desktop. Das hebe ich auch mal auf, weil das gibt es ja nirgendwo mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, ich muss den Chat fragen. Ach so Blast RNG, der Typ, der wurde gebannt,
weil er seine, ich habe keine Ahnung. Daube hat seine Freundin verkloppt, aber ich bin
mir echt nicht sicher, deswegen behaupte ich, ich sage gar nichts. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich
habe keine Ahnung. Stimmt nicht, was ich sage. Ich habe echt keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nur,
dass er gebannt wurde.
Macht es gut. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Bis dann. CU.